[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
food
[Music]
food
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
dammit
baby what have i done
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
baby
[Music]
two
[Music]
father reminds me of a wonderful idea
[Music]
baby whatever
[Music]
dammit
baby what have i done
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
you know
[Music]
you know
you know
you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
food
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
food
hello hello hello welcome to the game
sport and they saga presents
saving for the next gen show we are very
excited to bring you the first save for
the next gen show
this is the very first event of its kind
blending the importance of finance and
preparation
for the next generation in console
gaming for those who don't know
my name is stephanie ijoma and i am the
founder of one of uk's leading black
gaming and entertainment platforms
called nay saga it is our mission to
champion diversity and inclusion within
the games industry
over the last five years we have hosted
a number of gaming community events
workshops and more to ensure that there
are better and safer spaces
for people within the games industry i'm
also a content creator myself
and a streamer too i aim to continue to
open up more opportunities
for my community my community i
represent are for the black and ethnic
minority
for me saga it is super important that
we ensure that
everyone matters naysag is for everyone
and my goal is to change the face of
gaming
we are very thankful to have partnered
up with gamespot in bringing unique
event
to highlight educate and prepare you all
for the next generation in console
gaming
gaming is everything but no one dwells
into the cost of being a gamer
being in the industry or how to navigate
within the games industry
so here's where saving for the next gen
comes in we're going to give you a full
stack show
with four incredible panels dedicated in
tackling each area
in gaming and finance while it's being
joined by some amazing guests who have
been taken on the games industry by
storm
our first panel the price of being a
content creator we will be joined by
five of your favorite youtubers
dominating the scene
afro send you excel and the xl is silent
mighty keefe
it's senpai broken games hdr and tiana
mercedes
and they will all be giving you an
insight on what it actually takes to be
a youtuber
how they started budgeting advice
they'll give to content creators who was
just starting out
and how to prepare for the next
generation in console gaming next we
have the game spotlight panel
see what i did there but we'll be
featuring three prominent figures
within the games industry giving you an
insight on how they've been navigating
throughout the years as well as giving
some exciting gamescom predictions
they are jan lopez founder of black girl
gamers
cam robinson and l silly wood for our
third panel we'll be speaking to
experts over at barclays games they will
be giving us all the information on who
they
are what they are doing to help within
the games industry from a financial
aspect and where you can find them
elaine moran and natalie o'java from
barclays games we'll be giving you an
insight on who they are
last but not least we'll be joined by
the elgato team for our tech talk panel
we'll be speaking to long-term elgato
partner michelle michie
as well as one of the elgato global
community managers sharice haim on how
to prepare
for the next generation and what elgato
are doing to prepare themselves what
advice they would give to those seeking
assistance with global tech brands
and giving advice on what to get for the
next generation of gaming this isn't a
gaming show without some games right
we will also be having some fun gaming
segments too where our youtubers will be
battling out against their chosen guests
with some recent titles that have just
been released i believe i've said enough
now
make sure you kick back grab a cuppa and
enjoy the show make sure you are
following and sharing gamespot and
naysagar across twitter
facebook and youtube throughout the
entire show we also do have a giveaway
so make sure you're watching throughout
the entire time we're here
don't forget to use the hashtag gamespot
naysagar nextgen
and enjoy the show
[Music]
hi guys my name is tiana mercedes um i
play mainly call of duty
and before call of duty i used to play
fortnite and that's obviously where i
started streaming and making content on
games
because i just wanted to show
everybody my skills because people used
to say i was good so i thought let me
show
everybody and connect with people and
chat with people while i'm playing so
yeah i mainly play shooting games but
mainly call of duty evil zone now
hi um i'm songpie i do um i stream on
twitch
and also i do videos on youtube i'm a
variety streamer and just i cover most
games on youtube
um at the minute i'm playing four guys
which is the greatest but most
frustrating game i've played in a long
time
um but yeah i'm streaming that at the
minute i'm really enjoying that but yeah
basically youtuber and streamer
excel excel is silent i do a bunch of
things twitch kind of on the side but
sometimes i do do that right now i am
playing ghost tsushima and everything
else i kind of don't know what i'm doing
it's just
i just make it up as i go pretty much it
what's going on everybody i'm broken
games hdr uh most people just call me bg
for short
uh content creator um i review games
um i'm a podcast host i talk about
gaming news
stream also kind of do a little bit of
everything so yeah right now i'm
playing a lot of road company just beat
ghost sushima
so yeah that's what i'm up to right now
hey everybody my name is mighty keith
i'm a content creator on youtube
i do just comedy skits about gaming
anime movies whatever kind of just comes
to mind or something i want to
talk about at the time and uh i i do
streaming just a little bit not as much
but um you know mainly i just play video
games uh
i'm on goes to sema right now as well
kind of waiting for that cyberpunk to
drop but you know
yeah that's one game i've been looking
forward to for the whole entire time
since
and they keep pushing it back
it'll be worth it hopefully hopefully
hopefully
so like myself i am a youtuber and i am
a streamer myself
and it's nice to get these type of
people on the panel because
they're able to give us an insight on
their journey how they started
and you know where they're at now so son
how did you start your gaming journey
and your youtube career
okay so it all started when i made an
instagram account i kind of
i had no one in real life who played
games
or was into anything nerdy or anything
like that so i made an instagram account
and then everyone was like you should
start youtube
so i started a youtube with my laptop
and
my laptop on my phone it was like a
really old phone
a couple years ago and then from there
it's just grew into something that
i didn't expect because it was a hobby
and then now the hobbies turned into a
job
so yeah it's kind of amazing how that
can happen
um starting something from a hobby
and now it's a career so yeah it's nice
yeah you know
normally like you fall across into it
and you kind of accidentally fall into
the games industry or
starting yeah it's true it's true tiana
um my journey started but basically the
same i had an old
rubbish laptop on my phone i was playing
fortnite and people used to say to me
you should stream it you should stream
it so i started streaming fortnite and
doing custom games on fortnight
and the way i used to read my chat was
on my phone literally i play the game
stream straight from my playstation on
my phone and yeah from then i built my
own little small community
and i've just been going from there
that's incredible
honestly the encouragement from your
friends as well it does help a lot
it does really cool does lads he wants
to take away
uh i guess i'll go um so i started
youtube uh
my it started like 12 years ago for me
when i was like i was a freshman in
college
and youtube was still very like you know
young back then there was no really like
uh structured communities and you know i
was just bored in my dorm room one day
and um
went on youtube saw people gaming
putting up gaming videos and i was like
you know i'm a gamer
you know i'm i think i'm better than
most of the people i'm watching so i was
like
why don't i just do this and i um you
know didn't really
think at all it would evolve into
anything um but i figured out you know
what i needed you know the i had a
laptop had to get a mic
i had to learn a little bit of video
editing and from there you know just
started playing games that i was
interested in and
um you know just the community kind of
like found me and flocked to me and
ever since then it's you know it's
became you know
just way more and opened up a lot of
opportunities for me um and
gained a community from it so yeah it's
been great
yeah and it's good to see like your
growth as well you know and how you've
been able to connect with each other
especially you being in the states
and me being in london gaming has been
something where you can bring so many
people together
keith afro who wants to go
um for me it was a game called naruto
storm 3.
uh my only thing i wanted to do was make
a clan
on youtube and just kind of like be the
best clan in you know a little community
over time it just kind of naturally was
a thing like my first goal was to make
enough money to get a pizza and then
once i got that it like did something to
me
and i needed more pizzas and i needed
just like more just i wanted to make it
into something more
um and then naruto stone four came
around and it just kind of took off into
its own thing i just
i i don't really know what i'm doing but
i'm having fun
so i'm going to be honest but yeah from
there it just became what it is
it's crazy and like to see the numbers
grown and just aesthetically people know
who you are
as well which is really really cool and
last but not least
um so when i was younger um
i used to play fighting games like
competitively right i would travel
around go to tournaments
uh participate and whatnot and so when
smash came out i wanted to play that
more competitively and i started with
super smash brothers brawl
competitively um
as time progressed you know i i met
friends met top players
and built kind of like a friendship with
a lot of people in the community
so by the time that uh the next
iteration of smash came out which was
smash 4
it started with the 3ds it came out for
that before it actually came out on the
wii u
and so just messing around
one day and i was like you know what i
have a camera why not use it i
recorded a video called things smash 4
players don't say
put it online just for my friends you
know what i mean like i said the friends
within the smash community
um and then the next day i found out it
like blew up on on reddit um
and people were asking for more and so i
was like all right i guess so i just
started giving
more smash content over and over and
over um
until i just yeah i'm here
that's kind of how it started everyone
just kind of accidentally fell up on it
and
they said oh well yeah okay let's just
make this into something
pretty much the same the same honestly
so when you guys first started out
did you have like a set budget on your
gaming equipment
you know did you know where the best
places were to shop at the time
how did you prioritize necessities so
you know
any gamer a mic is super important but
also a headset
you know where did you come in to play
with what was the most important
what budget you had and stuff like that
so i thought i'd be really thrifty
and i went to ebay and amazon
so i got secondhand things off ebay i
was at uni at the time when i first
started so i was like i didn't have much
money at all
i went and i got my um elgato uh capture
card
super cheap it was like 40 pounds wow
exactly like someone was selling that
off quick
so i just got that up and then i just i
just got a really cheap headset i went
on amazon got
a mic with really good reviews but it
was five pounds with my little laptop
and i just started from there and i had
everything for like
a year until i got my first camera which
was 60 pounds and i've only just
upgraded
you know i've only just upgraded that
now yeah and one thing everybody should
know is
like you know everybody came from like
these kind of crude beginnings
of a setup like nobody's set up was
perfect uh
at the start like we had a whole bunch
of struggle setups and struggle
equipment and everything like that
um and you know sometimes you may have
to start out that way and
it's you know it grows into something
you know just way more impressive
and uh you know you just learn a lot
more over time as far as like budgeting
and the
and the best equipment to buy but it
starts in uh you know humble beginnings
um for sure
no i feel like for me a lot of the
equipment that i
got and learned of you know to get all
came from i guess
a very light form of networking like it
just i
always always hear people talking about
like elgato or like blue snowball
or just like things that uh were very
common easy
pickups for people that just started
doing youtube what have you so those are
things that i got over time
um i guess money-wise how i saved the
time i lived in the hood right so i
didn't really have like a lot
of good options to get money with just
the life i had to live
but you know it's one of those things
like if you really want to make
something happen it's like what are you
going to do
for uh you know the thing that you want
the most right and that was kind of how
i looked at it
making sure that my goals for what i was
doing to get what i wanted
were always on the positive side of
things and um i did what i had to do
to kind of get what i had to get and um
just kind of flipped it and
made it so i don't do something like
that ever again to get there
but yeah that's the goal on this that's
the goal like you said if it's something
that you really want to do you're going
to have to do it by any means necessary
you know yeah just make sure you're safe
when you do that
i know we touched upon earlier about you
know you switching from
the transition from a nine to five to
full time did
you know i guess you your savings and
your full-time job and
you know stuff like that uh well to be
honest with you um
when i start so back when i uploaded the
first
youtube video i was working as a server
um at a buffet area and i don't know if
anyone's worked as a server or server as
a buffet
before but when people go to buffets
and they go and get their own food they
feel like they don't need to tip the
server because they're getting their own
food that's just the way people think
so the money was never really good it
was never actually good in there
uh you get like a dollar maybe or 50
cents two dollars who knows but
so i didn't have too much of a saving um
i was also still in school it's like my
last year of college
um by the time i
left i like back in 2018 when i decided
i'd just go full time youtube
um it was kind of just like
it's either i make this or i don't and
if i don't well at least i said i did it
uh and i'll just pick up the pieces from
there um so i didn't really have a
segments account
it was like because either if i i make
this or i don't
so uh i think i'm doing all right so far
which i'm happy for
yeah honestly like i said especially you
know
from the american side of the youtube
community you know there's a
group like a big gaming community in the
uk that love
you know you guys and you guys are
normally the go-to when i say oh
do you guys only like black male content
curators and
these are the three that you know that
are recommended so yeah
you know you guys are doing pretty all
right that's awesome you know
so in terms of you know growing you know
your own personal brand
and you know what are the like
challenging bits like growing your own
personal brand especially from
i guess a youtuber aspect a content
curator your personal life and from a
financial aspect
i found it challenging i guess
separating
the pleasure and business side to things
i don't know because me
personally i'm very like workaholic like
that's just me so it's like
you know with youtube when it starts
turning into a job or just when you
start seeing progress
it's very easy to just like throw
everything that you know you your
visions all that stuff
into uh your dream and it's easy to lose
sight of things
i think there's like a term the tectonic
treadmill or something like that where
you get something that you really wanted
and you still want more
and you still keep on wanting more and
more and more yeah i think it's very
it was always hard for me to realize
okay i'm good here
let me be happy right because um it's
just it's a game in its own right like
when you
are doing something um for social media
attention or
you're you know becoming an influencer
like that influence itself i feel
is a drug to an extent right like you
love the positivity you love the energy
and it's just i think it was really
challenging for me to
kind of just disconnect and uh i don't
know like make sure
i'm still whole grounded as i'm like
throwing myself
like everything i got pretty much into
this set thing so
i think it was a lot of um realizing
when to like turn off
you know just like like get off of
social media get off all that stuff
like it protect my mental health you
know i think that was
for sure my my biggest hurdle with it
i agree it's hard because people feel
like they know you people feel like they
need to
be in your life know like everything
you're doing 24 7.
so sometimes it can be the struggle of
like separating the two
have you had any troubles or hurdles
with that
um not in the past recently yes
um and i think it's just because i think
it's just the nature
of of uh publicity or or notoriety
um eventually you're gonna get to a
point every you know
everybody i believe to a point where um
social media is just re it can be really
really toxic
to your mental just harping back to what
afro said
uh and the positive positivity is always
great and it's always
it's it's amazing but you know just
the more you get the more the more
opinions you have the more you talk to
people the more
uh everything you do the more you're
intertwined with the gaming community
the more people see you
it's gonna be more people more different
opinions people are gonna have of you
and so eventually
you know it's not always gonna be
amazing so that's just something you
gotta deal with
um that's just something you gotta
learn how to be like okay i shouldn't
be on twitter for five hours of the day
i should probably just check it a few
times and then come back
um in terms of having a brand yeah your
brand is you
so anytime you do something amazing that
affects your brand
anytime you do something you know
questionable that's going to affect your
brand so always keep that in mind
when building it up um and and to have a
bit of tact
uh when it comes to conversations or how
you approach anything because
you can't just do everything the way
other people do
um like i said depending upon your
notoriety
it has been a very weird time for
everyone around the world
you know during coving and navigating
luckily gaming has always been at home
it's always been a pleasure at home
and especially for our you know jobs our
hobbies it's predominantly being at home
has there been any sort of change in you
know
your source of income in terms of
projects or has it actually amplified
and given you more opportunities um
for me i feel like it's given me more
opportunities because
i've done more normally i probably would
have gone to work
came home not thought about oh there's a
pandemic i need to you know
work harder now but i've worked harder
and i've um
collaborated with more brands than i did
last year and
it's been it's the coroner's obviously a
bad thing
but for me personally um i've done a lot
more
due to the like having to do more
because of the virus
so it's a negative but it's been a
positive in terms of
work for me um
um yeah i agree with that like obviously
like you said
corona you know and over 19 is a
horrible situation
um but there's been uh
just i've been just been able to take
advantage of it um
i know a lot of people unfortunately
obviously you know lost their their jobs
because of this because they can't go to
work
you know i've been blessed enough that
my job um
i can work from home um pretty much
because all i do is just edit and write
and um you know i think even after all
of this clears up
i think you know we should just be able
to stay home anyway but that's besides
the point
um but yeah since i've been able to like
stay home
uh my pro my productivity when it comes
to like my content creation
um game reviews pretty much everything
i do i've been able to give it a lot
more attention a lot more focus
and you know gorgeous grow my brand a
lot more and people
and i'm i'm i'm i like to stay home a
lot anyway i'm not
the uh i'm outgoing but
i don't necessarily like to spend most
of my time outside like when they say
people should um you know stay home i
was doing that anyway you know
this is no different for me i was doing
that anyway and i was staying home
playing games
as much as i as much as i could so um
you know i was way ahead of you all on
that but
but uh yes i've been able to play a lot
more games
um beat a lot more games review them um
interact with uh my audience and
my subscribers and uh pretty much just
make the best of it and uh i think
um even somebody like me who likes to be
inside it
it does uh it does become monotonous
sometimes and it starts to
uh work on your mental like i've been
inside without doing the
some of the things that i like to decide
like go to a restaurant go to a football
game something like that
that stuff starts to like eat at you
mentally
um but now we have to you know
rely on video games even more
to keep us like sane and uh and
entertained and i think we
you know appreciate this hobby a lot a
lot more
because of it because if i didn't have
this hobby i don't really know what i
would be doing
inside um besides maybe watching netflix
so i definitely
you know uh the the gaming thing is is
like probably one of the best things to
have during
um this horrible situation
agreed definitely
for me i would say it's kind of been the
same more or less
i think it would be less because what i
tend to do a lot is travel
um more to like brands for like e3
and stuff like that so you know there's
none of that now so
i'm more so home uh i guess in some ways
it's no it's pretty much the same like i
guess i i would do stuff i guess with
brands now
um stuff similar to this like on a zoom
caller on discord
uh i guess the only thing i've did i've
noticed for sure is like comments
being different like since everybody's
at home is either a lot more
uh longing like you know deep meaningful
comments type b
or a lot of people being angry and i've
noticed a lot more people being angry
than prior
so it's i felt like on a very thin line
with
my opinions that i have to give because
people are just ready to come at you but
100. it's actually wild
um uh yeah for me kind of just like
everybody else covet
uh didn't really hit me um
as hard because i was home anyway
so i didn't really do too too too much
um
in terms of like going out too late
because i would spend most of the time
working so by the time it's time to go
out you know it's like
almost like nine ten o'clock and i don't
know man i feel like i'm getting old i
just want to go to sleep now
i want to go to sleep after that i'm
done with work uh but my friends they go
out and party
but now everyone has to stay at home and
no one can go party so
there's that um i will say this though
uh i thought it was very interesting in
terms of when when you hear about
youtube
uh and you hear about like the uh how it
can be fragile
because you know you're kind of on your
own you know there's no like 401k
there's no health benefit or health
insurance etc etc for most of it it's
kind of just like you're doing your own
thing
uh and a lot of people will opt out of
that type of lifestyle or
that type of living because of the
security that comes with having a
regular nine to five um everyone at
the nine to five i was at has been
pretty much let go of
because of this covered thing so i just
thought it was a little odd or
not odd but an interesting way a
perspective
of how things that could look
kind of fragile actually are are
prospering
in a pandemic which is which is odd
but that was just a little little take i
for somebody who's you know just started
i guess or
you know they love youtube but they do
want to make it and they do want to make
that one source of income
but then what are the other ways you
know you guys could recommend
and you know give advice on to people
who are watching
merch shirts
uh shirts uh sponsors
i think the one thing for sponsors that
i can give advice to make sure you get
more of
is uh learn how to talk i guess like you
know the the dialogue making sure
you know you're worth so you can get
like the best out of like deals that you
get your way like the networking side of
it
twitch i guess twitch was also like
something that
separated the revenue i guess you could
say
and i guess i guess that's that's really
it i mean there's like the meta for
talking stocks
and i i have i don't do that anymore
since call bid
oh wow so merch is really a thing and um
you know the sponsorship side as well
which is something i wanted to you know
touch up on because
um while we recently partnered anyways
but for those who i guess looking for
sponsorship
you know especially to help them out
financially
and especially going into the next
general you know gaming because gaming
again is expensive and
everyone is trying to prepare themselves
for the playstation 5 for the xbox um
series x
for somebody who again want to start out
streaming content creating or they're
just gamers and they just want to be
prepared for themselves
what kind of advice would you give in
terms of
you know tvs to buy or monitor to
purchase mics
and in a sense of what kind of
tools will people learn in terms of
softwares and stuff like that as
a content creator ah
man that's that's like a deep rabbit
hole you know because
the first you know advice i would give
them i think like keith i
alluded to this earlier is um no it was
actually
afro i think it's just learning to be
satisfied with what you have
because you can go down that path of
always looking for better equipment
there's always going to be
a better headset a better monitor um
better a better camera right once and
this is i've had i've changed my setup
at least maybe three four times like
in the past year like i'm talking about
major changes and that's something that
i've you know had a
had a issue with until i finally um
settled down like okay i'm gonna keep it
this way and i'm satisfied you gotta
learn you know how to be satisfied
um within your budget and uh
learn learn to just do incremental
you know upgrades and not feel like you
have to upgrade everything
at once um and as far as just
you know the budgeting and the earning
money
if you're going to get into this i
wouldn't say i would recommend you don't
get into this
with the objective that i'm going to
make a certain amount of money i'm going
to
you know get some quick money off of
this
like we all said we kind of just we're
just we
we all just love gamers and we just fell
into this by accident you have to
love what you're doing um there's a lot
of people who
uh pursue what's trending at the time
what game is
popular and um what seems to be
uh getting a lot of views of the time
and they try to do it and it fails and
it's because you didn't really you know
do that organically
you were just following the trend you
got to do what
you like what you're passionate about
and then you'll gain a community off of
that
because you don't want you know a fake
community that you just gained
by following what was popular at the
time so you know it's just
gotta uh it's just gotta happen um
organically and like
like you said uh sponsors um
you know views you can use youtube and
twitch don't feel like you gotta be
uh bottled into one because i there's a
lot of um
i think nowadays people seem to start on
twitch
more than starting on youtube that's
that's the change that i noticed like
from
when i started like usually people
started on youtube they were then they
but now most gamers i think are starting
on twitch and there's a lot of twitch
creators that i feel like you know you
do great on youtube also you should put
some of your videos on youtube
so you know use all the avenues that are
that you could uh possibly find
yeah i agree i mean um another place is
instagram
i guess instagram you don't play games
with instagram but you can
showcase that you do um for me i've got
partnerships
uh that want me to post the gaming stuff
on instagram rather than on youtube
i mean i've got more followers on
youtube than i do on instagram
but that's where they want their stuff
to be put out
because not many people on instagram i
guess are
hyping over a certain product and they
want that out on instagram
you can get instagram sponsorships in
terms of gaming too you don't have to
just like you said you don't have to put
all your eggs in one basket
you've got instagram you've got tic tac
i know you sorry
everyone likes tip talk and you've got
uh youtube twitch there's so many
different places you can just put all
your stuff you don't have to
keep it in one place like just expand
do put everything everywhere because
you're going to get a following from
twitter
and that following is going to go over
to youtube that following is going to go
over to your twitch and it's like a big
triangle like a
you know so yeah that's it just
diversify go everywhere do everything
good equipment doesn't necessarily equal
like
you're going to instantly make it or
good content because i see a lot of
people when they start off
not a lot but some you know you'll see
someone who has like a
really crazy camera really crazy like
lights everywhere and they're just
starting out
and it's like i feel like once you do
that you're adding a lot of stress on
your results without what you're going
to get when you're starting out
it's like it's better to to look
at like what you should be spending
relative to where you're starting
because you know like you know success
isn't guaranteed on this place really
oversaturated so
you you know you can make it happen for
sure but
you shouldn't be you know acting like
like like balling out right away like be
smart about it
yes that's my one thing i'd say
yeah i i i agree because when i first
started
i never had a mic or anything i just
used the headset mic and p
and i used to have roughly like 30 30
viewers a day
when i first started streaming on
youtube and people will
watch me like they'll still watch me
even though i didn't have good
good quality stuff because they're
coming for me if
that makes sense and the first thing i
actually invested in was
a microphone i still use the playstation
camera and still stream from my
playstation but the first thing i would
say to invest in
is a is a microphone so people can he
can hear you clearly
so and yeah oh yeah i mean a microphone
is definitely i i would also agree
that's probably the best thing
the first thing just to to kind of
invest in
um and then a very a very good quality
camera but in terms of like
you know what do you do for money before
you know youtube or twitch whatever
starts to build up
um yeah all the sponsors if you can get
them
and um the merch as afro said
um but honestly also if you want i mean
a part-time job wouldn't hurt either
like that's that's kind of what i was
thinking about doing if
like when i left my my job and went on
youtube
um to try to make it full time i was
like worst case scenario i could get a
part-time job to help out with just the
bills
until this this you know
is able to support itself um and when i
say far time i don't know if that might
that might be different from
uh you know different states or
different countries or anything
but what i mean part-time i mean like
you know nothing more than like 20 hours
a work week or something like that
just so that you still aren't you still
have time to you know focus on
uh your passion and you're not like
exhausted at the end of the day
you know what i mean and there's still
that sense of flexibility as well
because exactly i still work full time
but the times that i work anyways it's
allowed me to still
you know work and run my brand hopefully
when the time does come i can fully
transition but
like you said still working is not a bad
thing at all
so i want to go a bit a little bit
deeper now
being a black content creator we often
face the struggles of being amplified
being noticed
you know being given opportunities by
our non-black counterparts
how do you you know equate your worth
and value to the potential clients and
how do you still let them know like
listen i'm just as good as you know if
not better because
with me i now don't believe in the
notion of working 10 times harder
because we shouldn't have to be working
10 times harder to be where we are
but especially with you guys who you
know built a name for yourself
and built a platform for yourself how
have you you know faced those kind of
issues being a black content creator
uh so with doing youtube i had a few
friends that were kind of along the
journey
and one of my friends had kind of like
been keeping up with me is my friend
named rhyme style
so if there was like let's say something
we get into together
that uh i'm just curious to see if
there's a difference in how we're
treated
i'll like sometimes like observe like
rhyme doing something that i'll ask and
the same thing he asked just to kind of
see differences or i'll ask rhymes
specifically to ask for this thing
that i just asked for to kind of see if
there's gonna be like any different
replies
um there's only been like two cases
where i noticed something like
very like like okay that's kind of
interesting
to where but like when i noticed i just
stayed away you know
i'd never believe in trying to fit like
a circle in a square space so if there's
like
any type of thought or differences like
that i just
don't see the point in trying to uh show
worth
you know if it's not seen right away but
i agree with that
same yeah i i i've never thought of it
like that actually but
i guess if a company is going to
offer someone else some even if you're
on the same level something completely
different to you
and there's an obvious reason why then
they shouldn't have the privilege of
working with you
um like they shouldn't have that so i
actually really agree with that
uh i mean i think that um
you know like for example with with my
podcast i i
have uh all black podcasts and it wasn't
necessarily my intention when i started
my podcast i'm going to have
you know all black members but that was
you know that was just my
close group of uh people that i
associated with on
on youtube and on the internet and
everything like that
and i think that you know youtube is
just an extension
of the real world and i think
people are attracted to uh
faces and voices that
sound like them and look like them
that's that's natural for
everybody so you and you know like being
the
um the minority of content creators on
youtube
uh there are some that you know will
look
uh for someone like i said who looks
like them and sound like them
and that may not be that may not be us
so there's some that you know i would
say the majority
don't care but there are definitely like
a demographic that
do care that uh isn't necessarily
interested in
um watching us because we have because
of how we sound and look and
i think that's uh sometimes the
challenge
um that we've uh had to face but um as
you all have said uh you know having a
a smaller dedicated uh audience that
really appreciates you
um you know that matters more than
necessarily having
like the biggest numbers right because
you know there's people in
my community that you know even even if
i haven't had a direct conversation with
them i recognize them as a long time
subscriber
um and you know those are the dedicated
ones that are
you know always there so yeah you just
got to appreciate those and the ones
that are
really there yeah
yeah i mean that's a good um that's a
good way to look at it
uh my myself i haven't really
uh had too much
like hurdles just yet the the difference
when when it comes to like how i feel
about
um any form of racism or any form of
like
setback because of skin color doesn't
come from like people
just straight up saying it it's more of
like stuff that does happen in the
shadows like afro was saying
um or um
me figuring feeling like my type of
comedy
is more so for like maybe the like
more urban urban culture or or
or i'm like like when i started smash
um super smash brothers um
my content was vastly different than
everybody else's content in there
because no one else really did skits
they always did like gameplay
stuff and it was everyone was so like
you know it's nintendo so you got to be
so happy go lucky yeah
you know what i mean and that's just not
me
that was just not me and i always felt
like that was going to be a hindrance
if i just ate in smash because i was
like whenever i modeled or i saw
like um youtubers who were
in nintendo or in smash that were a lot
higher
i like their archetype was just
completely polar opposite of how i was
so i i was kind of like all right um it
was a gift in the curse for that to
happen because it also
told me all right you got to do more
than just smash keep please um
but it also felt like my style of comedy
um
kind of um got more well received
amongst like
i guess black people or or or more
ethnic people
um not to say that like you know
i don't have and um people
that get that's only uh black or ethnic
people that
that find it amusing but it just felt
like it
earlier on in my in my career that that
was like
the majority of people who watched me
hmm
no i don't know what it is now but
that's how i feel
no it's definitely well received
definitely well received and
you know i wanted to just get into
finally about what was your most
cherished piece of equipment that you
invested in
you know when you finally said okay this
is
like okay i'm now taking this seriously
for me i think it would have been
probably my gaming pc yes that's like
my baby now that's something i've
heavily invested in that's something i
know that i have to
actually use but it's really helped in
terms of editing
content creating streaming you know i'm
able to now
be i guess a cross-platform brand you
know i can play on pc
i can play on my ps my xbox or my switch
but because of the pc it's allowed me to
provide that sort of access
so yeah i think i would agree mine would
be my gaming pc also because
before i'll literally take me the whole
day to edit
on my laptop like until you get a pc you
don't realize how much easier it is to
do things
on your pc than on your phone or on
the laptop because i literally used to
edit on my phone and then i got a laptop
to edit it on my laptop so when i got a
pc it was like oh my gosh
like i could put more content like it's
it's crazy it's so different like
and then and it speeds things up and it
makes me want to do more because before
i block oh
i go i gotta edit now i got edit but now
it's more like oh yeah i can edit
just get out the way put it out and yeah
um
i think for me it was my chair because
like i said that to you to be honest
like the earlier days like i saw in like
a wooden chair and that really made me
not gonna lie my back just felt like a
dorito chip it just was not a good time
then when i finally got like like i
saved up a lot it was like a dx racer
not this one but
like the first one i had which looks
absolutely jacked up because i treated
that chair like a bed like i was so
thankful for that thing for a while i
just slept in it like i just never
wanted to believe it
that was like mind-blowing i could sit
in something all day
and not feel pain that was great yeah
cause when you're here editing and then
playing
editing again you need that comfort you
know
absolutely uh yeah it's definitely my
gaming rig
um i always try to have like the
strongest
card in there um like i do have a you
know a 20 80
ti in there right now and um you know
32 gigs of ram and you know you know the
high stems
actually all that stuff that's that's
the one part of my setup where i don't
like skimp on
price and like when new stuff comes out
for the for my rig
i definitely like upgrade to like the
strongest stuff um
yeah that's that's where you i
definitely have dumped most money in but
i look at it as an
investment right i've i can honestly say
i've never regretted it because i mean
that's your
that's your workstation that's where you
do
everything from so it's actually
it's definitely definitely worth it um
you know the the cam you know i use a
dslr camera that
uh that was an investment in quality so
you have to look at everything
you know like uh and investment and it's
not necessarily
um a waste and you know think about
you know sometimes simplicity
is uh is best minimalism is best
because my my setup used to be a lot
more complex
and elaborate and i really like kind of
dumbed it down and got rid of stuff that
really wasn't necessary that's another
thing people need to be aware of you
don't need to
have your desk full of a whole bunch of
gadgets and a whole bunch of devices
just
what you really need um so yeah
it's definitely my my rig where i spent
the most money
okay so um because i stream now
it's my my pc but if i didn't start
streaming
it would probably be my capture card
because when you're on youtube obviously
you need to do
upload gameplay and you need a capture
card to be able to do that
so it would definitely be the capture
card if i wasn't streaming
but now oh my god i'm loving streaming
so it's definitely
my pc for me it would be uh
my camera just because uh most of my
videos are skits
um so whenever
i like i want something to look clear or
have a perfect angle or whatnot
i used to have a camera that didn't have
a
the monitor on it couldn't flip
right so i i had to just record myself
and just pray the shot was in focus you
know what i mean
and every time it wasn't i was like
great i just recorded for 10 minutes and
let me just record the whole thing all
over again
and that was such a waste of time it was
so it was so bad so when i finally got
one with a flip screen
and i could uh see if it's focused and
get a better lens
and and not have to worry about a whole
bunch of stuff that i had to it
made content creations so much easier
for me
no i definitely i literally just
invested in the m50
because it had like the mirrorless i
have that one that's good that's good
thank god just like i just i had to
improvise and if it looked good it
looked good if it didn't it didn't yeah
you know no but honestly it has been
super like amazing and inspiring having
all of you guys because again i've
i watch you guys i'm a fan of you guys
and i wanted to make sure that
this panel is a panel where
people can watch this and look back and
just say okay i've listened
i've got gathered advice i'm basically
able to be prepared for the next genera
you know in gaming
and i wanted to let you guys know in
regards to
how well-received you guys are not just
in the uk but around the world you know
like i said um earlier to keith that
everyone does recognize your efforts
everyone does recognize your talent
people do watch you you know when i ask
my friends oh
who are some of your favorite like
gaming content creators they mention
your names
so it's really good to have you you know
again gamespot are amazing to provide
this sort of thing
and finally what are your predictions
for gamescom
oh man i i so i haven't like with
with covet and everything i you know and
i haven't really given much thoughts
into
these events as much because they're you
know it's all like digital now and
um i just feel like you kind of concern
yourself less with like
you know knowing exactly what's going to
happen but
i mean i know you like ubisoft is going
to be there and um
you know ea you know all the like major
third-party one
uh uh developers are going to be there
so i'm definitely interested in seeing
stuff from them
um even bethesda and bandai namco so
i'm looking forward to see what they'll
have in store to show but that's about
it
for me i'm excited to see how it's all
gonna be done
because i believe this is the first time
the whole thing's gonna be like an
online thing
yeah the virus so i'm just excited to
see
i know there's a youtube event um which
i'm going to be going to
how all that's done so i haven't got any
predictions as such
i'm just sat there excited
[Laughter]
give me that and i'll be good
yeah uh you know what i'm with you
get it get a new number how about that
let's get that
something about breath of the wild too
man i just uh they they showed it
the other day actually yeah man breath
of the wild is still my favorite game i
didn't yeah i love that game
that amazing but i love it and that's
the first zelda game i've ever played to
that's oh really
wow yeah what a good first game to play
though
definitely is definitely and i just want
them to
say something about the second one um
and if they do
that's all i need
i hope they talk about metro crime
that's something i'm looking for i need
a new metroid crime game that's not
something at least that's a little bit
we've been saying that for so long that
haven't though
yeah yeah just don't get your hopes
without anything okay
tiana are you looking forward to
anything in particular i'm just
i'm the same as son i'm just looking
forward to how to see how they're going
to do it see how it's going to be laid
out and presented you know i mean i
haven't got
any predictions as such i'm just excited
to see how they're actually going to do
it
um yeah definitely definitely we're
excited i'm excited to see how it's
going to unravel
what games are going to show us because
the game's going to be like the crucial
crucial one e3 is like the
space wave but gamescom is when they
really shoot the games out
so yeah like guys it has been an
absolute honor to have
you on this panel you know and make sure
you guys are all following them
on youtube twitter instagram twitch
these are like these should be your next
favorite youtubers
ever period okay thank you so much for
joining me
and stay tuned
[Music]
not the other way around all right okay
let's go
i'm ready okay so you just have me like
talking to myself in this person
basically nice
nice all about me i've had practice now
i'm ready to go
i'm ready absolutely i'm like i went
back to slouching
could you oh god yeah this is gonna be
it
for me i'm gonna win around all right
oh break through the doors this isn't a
bad one this isn't too bad this is okay
wait till i get like stepped on right
and not in a good way
in the worst way oh yeah because this
one you count getting stamped on
yeah i got trampled pushed to the side i
ended up
elsewhere you know and someone like just
threw themselves at me and it was it was
kind of terrifying
kind of terrifying okay we're ready to
go
where are you there you are i'm in the
front i'm gonna follow you
i think your door's gonna work yes it
did
everything roses is right i'm gonna
follow okay maybe not
you had too much hope in me too oh
no
oh no everyone's ah i'm gonna start
grabbing people
if this continues
sun's getting hands up getting handsy
okay go on now you know what i think
this is the worst one because you always
get pushed to the side
this is like how i felt in high school
i'm feeling it all over again the
nostalgia
not in the good way yeah
come on i can qualify you can't even run
on this game
oh my right rage quit
please rage quit with me okay rage
quitting right now let's do this
together we're in this together
till the end my real time for one and
one for all
you're trying too hard
get lost but i can't
you're my husband i go wherever you're
going i'm going to divorce you if you
carry on
you meant oh will you you went quiet
therefore i'm sorry
you want me better jk thank you true no
toxic girl 101 don't remind me
this noise when you're not playing this
game all i hear is
in my head the music is so annoyingly
catchy okay this is just so yummy
yeah but it's annoying
you just go to work and then this is all
you hear i'm putting the glasses on for
this
this is this oh seriously i mean
business
okay imagine i wouldn't mind i'll get
some like free publicity right here
i was gonna say let's do it on stream
you know but i didn't know if like
you wanted to or not i was game for that
but oh my god don't push me up already
then everyone would see how bad i am
you're good at this game oh no you're
behind me now
you told me you said oh grab everybody
so everybody includes you you know
complaining against
the truth i'm not special anymore i see
who you are
that's why i only i've only grabbed you
yeah
you're here that's not gonna be touching
me in it you're only the person that got
the g
there you are you're so easy to
recognize in the outfit you know
that was the whole point oh what the
hell why does my screen do that
yes i'm gonna qualify oh
no what okay so
clearly you need to just not tell people
that you're going to qualify because you
just mess yourself up
did you qualify yes i just arranged quit
let's go again okay
no i don't want to buy one you can't
have
every single one of your bits of footage
being you getting eliminated son
i can i can and i will
that's it okay let's go
come on you've got this
focus on the game i'm like i can't focus
like this is too hard
i guess your mental breakdowns on stream
is also fun
exactly that's me constantly having a
breakdown on stream
and there's me just an innocent
bystander and you're just like
rose is shorter than everyone in the
world
okay you know what it is that no one
believes that i'm sure
so you're the only person to confirm
so but you're shorter than me so it's
like yeah i'm sure but rose is shorter
but no one knows my height either why
are you you're very short
i'm just like you're definitely like you
basically just told them earlier that i
was
only for a foot and i was like excuse
you yeah i know you're not i know wait
how are you
like there was there was no 411 it was
like chris is for a fella
great i think you're like you're so
savage it was really mean i was like
okay
no it didn't like it was fine to be like
oh you're sure but then you're just like
okay bear in mind guys he has like no
height all together
you know what that because when i first
saw you i was so happy i was like oh
you're shorter than me this is my god so
you're so fantastic oh my days it's
great
it's cute though
oh my gosh no what is going on
ah stop getting friendly with the balls
and just qualify
yes thank you 41 41 did you see that
yeah this close i was this close
who's the mercury where are you i would
say three was you
okay they just flexed on me like that
missed the top three we get it
i'm sorry i'm from the fighting fighting
games community i can't
compete because i'm crap but here i can
flex
really but you run it you run it
and you're just not competing because
you're not that good
no i i know you you're better than me if
you think they're better than me
it's not hard though is it really it's
not an accomplishment to be better
better than me at games always
fail together right yeah it's fun
failing you know what i do want to
become really good at a game though
i want to be really
i fell off already
i'm always falling off why are people
grabbing me up
that's you that's you
did you fall on you
yeah i did i followed you off oh
we're in this together
[Music]
i like this new dive thing that i've
discovered today i've been playing it
for
all this long and never knew about the
dive you know is that true
yeah that's bad isn't it
really i didn't know about the live
that's why i was so bad you you think my
people in chat would say yeah yeah son
you're not diving
you're diving enough yeah i know right
they're just like they just sit there
like
a few hours later like oh you haven't do
you know how to die
yes someone said someone said oh guys
does she know how to dive
no i don't know how to dive that's why
i'm not diving
do you know i was supposed to play four
guys today on stream and i ended up
playing kill it with fire
oh it's so good right it's so addictive
and so
stupid i love it it is so cool my
favorite weapon is the ferrari tan at
this point
i've not got that far why is it so hard
to to kill it to kill it with it
kill the spider with a block
yeah i did i did and i eventually got it
could you
i quit i raged quit and then went to the
next level i was like nope
not today not today oh my gosh
[Music]
yes so even with the mile touching right
we got it we did it even with you trying
to hold me down
i qualified we did this together no
fault enough for us
the one remaining imagine if we win this
imagine if i win this like if you win
this isn't that shocking
if i win this oh yeah if i win this is
very shocking
what is this third game now yeah i think
so
what time is it about it matters and
well doesn't matter
a bit to be fair oh yeah i need to send
this to steph you know it does smell
how long how much have you played of it
can you
oh kill it with fire now how much you've
played with this
today today i was supposed to but i got
caught up with a a
huge just chatting segment which i
rarely ever do
you know when it's so easy to be to be
caught just chatting isn't it
to be honest yeah like the thing is
right our streams today were so
different i was all like
positivity
take care of yourselves your weirdos and
i'm like
this drama happened to me
i know i was covering the drums no
positive energy for me
right oh wait bananas what was it please
be a banana
yes yes oh my gosh
that's so great how all i remembered was
the banana
okay now what i'm on the grape the
strawberry
was there a strawberry the graces
cherries and oranges
it's a cherry not a strawberry someone
pushed me off the side of this game
before
yes i know which one someone pushed me
off the side of it
wait they're pushing me off now no
why are they so toxic in this uh poor
guy's place they're so toxic aren't they
they really are these beans are so tight
do not know that they're dressed up like
weird animals and there's so how can
they think they look cool no one looks
cool in this game
and they're out here trying to push me
oh my god i'm on top of someone
i'm so excited this is it for me i'm
gonna win four guys
this is it i'm gonna take that w
and show it to the whole entire world
that's what's gonna happen
let's go yes
i'm so ready i'm so ready i'm so excited
i've not really came this far before i
think i've got to near we've got one
more left
i think so yeah oh my god i could
actually win
i could win today oh my god
this is really making me feel
hot and bothered oh no no
no no i don't want this slime
i can't i want this slime yeah i've not
even got to the glue i've never got to
the top of this game before it looks
this
is disgusting looks difficult
oh great where are you uh second row
why is i do you jump to the side i
always
uh fail at that and even then these
people are bumping into me and just
pushing me off already
it's really hard isn't it do you hate
this one too
is it just me do i want it do you hate
this one
um i don't really hate it to be honest
i'm full of so much hate no
how do i get back up
okay great i'll just go the normal way
really
everyone makes me sick in this game
did you fall autumn yeah the same place
where you
did okay i'm not having it but ending
the game play everybody goodbye
bye everybody oh my gosh that's how we
do it i'm so upset
eliminated look at us sad
i might even just cry
all right let's ready up then let's get
this
w i'm ready to get a
w oh i'm in the front line oh
oh it's time i'm about to put the
burners on them
the burners have been activated on our
trips
oh no
plan it was all planned
burners on them
what the i can't get up there
oh my god bro what is happening i'm
getting trampled
what's going on no no no no
oh my god oh my god i'm in a i'm in an
infinite bro
what the i finally hell
it i finally made it i was in the
infinite that's crazy
nice i got three
all right yeah yeah yeah
go go go go yes
[Applause]
oh
are you serious i fell off again
no i keep falling off why
[Music]
bro he hit bro get out the way oh my god
get off me
dude this dude literally no it fell off
why
did you qualify i'm eliminated wait what
so even if i qualify you don't qualify
no
i don't think that oh that sucks fall
guy 1487. yeah
wait what i think i'm 1473 though
what i'm fall guy 1473 i'm pretty sure
i think and i'm 14 something what
did i die from that michael street i
don't see i don't see no 1487.
1473 is what i am
oh okay 47 i see 14.73
yeah man why do i keep getting hit bro
you sliding off bro oh my god please
all right we out all these seesaws bro
everyone's trashing the see-saw
can i get a w please let me get this w
let me get this
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no
all right we out oh no oh no
yes we out
who plays like that oh my god
that's how people play in these games
who plays like that
he legit just tried to stop me
i'm losing because other people are oh
my
jesus i've never done this one oh oh
moving backwards and you have to dodge
oh
easy money let's go top 10 again
top 10 again let's get this
w they must have added these i've never
done or seen any of these yet
there are still games i have not played
hmm what oh i guess you have to
i'ma let somebody go before me because i
don't know what though oh find the path
you gotta take the piccolo route oh
yeah the box disappears why
[Applause]
oh oh oh watch out watch out oh my god
oh no no no so you had the right idea
wait they disappeared
no i think there's multiple ways to get
in there let's go
oh
this is trash no
no oh my god this is so bad
this is so bad
i'm gonna cut them off
you oh i'm doing so bad i'm doing so
bad you're at the bottom i'm at the very
bottom
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
baby
hello i'm ellis lee woods i'm a video
games presenter and journalist
hi everyone i'm jane lucas i'm the
founder of black girl gamers
and yeah it's pretty much me hey i'm cam
robinson
and um i'm a video games presenter and
also run a production company called
double jump
amazing so we're going to get right into
it so how did you guys start your gaming
career
uh so i started off i actually started
out as a political journalist for the
bbc so completely different
um and basically whilst i was there i've
kind of always loved games that's
something i've always been really
passionate about so
i asked if i could kind of sneakily
cover them on the side in my own
free time and luckily for me they said
yes although they did call it an
infantile hobby
but they did let me do it so yeah that
was fun
and yeah so basically it's kind of gone
from there i was very lucky that
at that point you know there wasn't a
lot of mainstream games journalism so it
meant that whenever people were looking
for somebody
you know my name would come up um from
there i kind of set up my youtube
channel
got my own tv show um i most recently
worked with playstation as the editor of
their youtube channel
yeah and now i'm freelance it's amazing
absolutely no honestly that's why we got
you for
our gamer girls night in panel in
january so you know i love that kind of
do-it-yourself
um kind of thing um so for me
i i think i'll have the weird background
i didn't study it i didn't have a kind
of side step into it i just created a
platform
um with a big mouth essentially um
so after just experiencing a lot of
sexism and racism
i decided to create a safe space for
myself and others in the in the
community
and so we've just grown that over the
years over five years now to have about
almost 7 000 women
globally um i run events diversity
consulting cultural
cultural strategy um consulting as well
because
a lot of game companies you know the the
growth of the industry has been quite
um there's been a lot of nepotism and i
think the culture and just
modern society is changing and to be in
touch with different audiences
and to be in touch with what is
progressive because people need
and companies need to talk to people so
i do black girl gamers but i also
do talks and that consulting piece as
well amazing
um i might challenge you for the weird
entry into gaming i actually studied uh
biology university so
that's why i just biochemistry oh wow
there you go
i think there is like i remember a
former colleague named jane douglas she
was a
nuclear nuclear physicist i think as
well so there's this kind of
science into gaming is a thing oh good i
don't think anymore
but yeah so um i actually started in
gaming by entering a presenting
competition and didn't win
so uh that's how you get in you don't
win things and um
yeah then i i pretty much i made a pilot
of a show that was about science and
video games
sent off to gamespot and this was about
nine years ago and yeah they got me the
job
um so and that bizarrely i run a company
with the guy who i randomly emailed
with this example video that i made so
kind of serendipity there
um so yeah if you don't it shows if you
don't win something doesn't matter just
keep trying
and you you know if you're if you're
dedicated enough hopefully
you should find a way in um yeah so
that's
and now i run a production company
called double jump and we
we work mainly in the games industry
with you know
nintendo bethesda 2k all the kind of big
production com sorry
the big game uh publishers we make video
game trailers or
social assets or pretty much any video
that they need
as well as like helping people live
stream and doing a bit of presenting on
the side so we try and do a bit of
everything which is uh
i think the most fun way to do work yeah
that is bad
typical yeah i really like everybody has
like
got into gaming the honors like the
unorthodox way
like you know not the conventional way
of going to uni studying gaming
then going into the gaming industry
everyone's kind of found their way
on their you know on their own like
myself and i think this is the perfect
panel as well because
people are able to see that there's not
one way to go into the games industry
so yeah so next question is what was the
transition like for you before covet
and what is it for you like now the
current climate that we're in
uh for me bizarrely it's not being too
bad actually so i
despite being presenter i kind of do a
lot of work from home anyway so i have
um you know a full studio set up at home
i have my brick wallpaper
um you know i've got i love it you know
so
i'm i'm kind of lucky you know i
literally have a full studio i have an
auto queue i have
a multi-cam setup that i can shoot live
from my flights i've got everything so
i've been very lucky that for me it's
been a very smooth transition
and in particular i think the games and
media industries tried to be hard to
feel
creative during this period they've
really you know put on fantastic events
and panels and and come up with
different ways to produce content so
you know i'm lucky that i've done lots
of kind of rewinding so i you know
hosted for the bafta games awards i
hosted the red carpet from my house
which was really strange it's a really
weird thing to say you've done that yeah
you know and then we've done things like
you know after panels and
just done it over zoom and in a way i'm
kind of a little bit scared if it's ever
going to go back to normal because it's
been
so simple and straightforward very
smooth transition that
you know it's it's kind of hard to to
imagine how we'll go back to
hiring out whole studios and having
massively expensive kind of on location
sets so i guess we'll see yeah that's
true
i think for me i'd take it two ways so i
completely echo what l had said so
you know gaming is a predominantly
digital space anyway
so there's a lot of digital stuff that
you can do anyway so i think
um for me i wanted to kobe actually
brought about an event that i've been
wanting to do for over a year
and um it made it it's more simple to do
because i didn't it i have a lot of a
global a very global audience my
platform has a very global audience so
attract to attract those people and get
them all in one space
digitally is the best way to do it so i
had the black girl gamer summit which
was
you know just people from all different
parts of the world and that
was brought about because i couldn't do
it irl and i didn't have the money to do
irl and i don't have the finance to do
it so why not do it digitally and get
sponsorship and say
that's how it happened and so kobe
brought that about and it was something
new and different that i was really
proud of
um like during covert obviously there's
been a whole
uh you know issue of police brutality
and the black lives matter movement
that's really affected my community um a
lot
and what we what i've seen is a lot of
solidarity
a lot of support a lot of love being
shared around the community
um which is like even more so than
before
i think because you know sometimes when
you have that common enemy you tend to
band together quite closely
and i think in gaming there's been that
reaction to that
um which has kind of had a ripple
in the industry in a way i don't know
how far that was going to travel
but there has been a ripple there and
it's been interesting to see how
companies have reacted to both covert
and that issue
because we've been hit with a double
whammy essentially it's not just been
one thing
it's been multiple things so um it's
been it was very interesting i would say
very interesting all the time
yeah it's interesting to hear
you know your how your experiences are
kind
of different from from what i've had in
a way in the sense that
i mean obviously because we're a
production company primarily usually
that means going places and filming
yeah it is the wonderful thing about the
games industry is that
i feel like throughout covered we've
probably all witnessed this all
other industries have suddenly looked at
the internet and being like oh wow did
you know the internet is a great way to
communicate with other people right
yeah yes we've been doing this for
decades um
i felt quite smug and then about you
guys all the way through this um
but yeah it's as a production company
that's it's been mixed for us because
on the one side we haven't been able to
go two places and film
i mean normally in a year we were quite
fortunate and do a fair amount of
international travel
going to you know developing studios
around the world and filming
on locations so it's been a shame not to
be able to do that but on the other side
we've kind of
um pivoted a bit and been making game
trailers
and jumping on opportunities like that
so there you know it's been okay there
is still work
out there um i think as far as broadly
industries go i think
we're very lucky i think gaming overall
is probably one of the
few industries which is faring fairly
well i mean
i'm not an expert on how it's been
affecting the development side of games
i'm sure there's been some difficulties
there
yeah but in terms of the media side and
the marketing side and the
communication side i think it's probably
one that's whether the storm
fairly well you're right especially when
you said about the development part
you know quite a lot of games have been
delayed due to everyone being moved at
home
and you know a lot of things are done
better in the studios but again
there is the comfort of playing games at
home doing stuff at home because gaming
is predominantly at home
so yeah we are very very lucky you guys
have kind of answered my next question
but i would say what have been
you know i guess the best things about
your line of work
during clovid you know it is an
unfortunate situation but again like you
said
gaming has been predominantly at home
but what has been you know
you know the best bits of working from
home i guess
i guess you know for me as i said it's
it's nice because it's i
just got to use all the very expensive
equipment i've had that you know hasn't
had quite as much use before and i'm
like finally this is going on
um but i think it's you know one of the
things that's been nice for me
is i do a lot of work and particularly
mainstream media i do a lot of what wbbc
you know people like that where i'm
often happy to kind of
talk about why games aren't dangerous
why games aren't going to turn your kids
you know violent why
so you know and i do that a lot and i
think one of the things that i've
loved during lockdown is just how many
people have
really embraced gaming how many people
have seen how much joy it can bring to
their lives to their children's lives to
their friends lives
and so it's been quite nice to me i've
done lots of different pieces
um you know i've had much more variety
in the kind of work i've been asked to
do so
you know i've talked more about things
like fortnight as an entertainment
platform and a storytelling platform or
i've been able to you know i made a
podcast documentary about
the science behind why games genuinely
positively affect your brain
um because people are kind of desperate
to hear that because you know they're
they're playing so much during lockdown
or their kids are playing so much during
what i'm down
but actually they want to hear why it's
positive and so it's actually been a
really wonderful opportunity for me
to to really kind of spread the good
word about gabriel
yeah exactly yeah have you heard about
all the lord and savior
um for me basically i'm gonna kind of
echo what cam said i did feel really
smart
because um people even asked me to talk
about
how to maintain a community online
because now not just
brands but actual companies that work
you know their employees how to maintain
positive employees
and sentiment and all of that stuff and
it's like well i've been doing this for
six years now i'm the expert in the room
yeah it's been super like different to
actually see
you know that that underground or
kind of other feel from gaming kind of
dissipates
um which is so cool because i think it's
we were
still a step ahead of the game pardon
the fun but we really were
um and i think that now companies are
starting to look at us that are really
actually we're not
weird geeky nerdy quote-unquote gamers
exactly that's in the basement that
cliche has kind of been risen like
getting rid of yeah i'm really enjoying
that um
the time during kotavid it's really just
bringing the community together
by events via internal and external
events you know spending more time
i get to spend more time with the
community because i'm not homeless all
the time
for the most part and you know it's just
nice to
be able to fortify the community work on
things that um
needed work on but just didn't have the
time at the time
delegate get to know more people get to
bring in more people it's been really
fun to show my love for the community
i call them like i call them my babies
even though they're grown women and
someone
older than me but like it's been really
fun to spend more time with them and get
to know them and just
play animal crossing and just have
little events and like it's been really
fun
that's been the highlight really
it's really great to hear like such
positive and
almost like silver linings and i hadn't
really thought actually l about the fact
that this is you're right this is such a
great opportunity for gaming to stand up
and say like hey look look at the
positive impact we have in people's
lives and
honestly i hadn't really thought of that
so that's it's great you mentioned it
um i think in terms of like for me
personally the good side of things is
you know being able to work
at home um is good in some ways because
i mean
we have a studio in south london which i
normally would go to and that's great
but it's nice to be able to
do a bit of mixing and i look forward to
the time we can get back there sometimes
for projects but there's something great
about
having the extra time that working at
home before to you and um
yeah being able to maybe have play some
games at lunchtime and all that jazz as
well so
there is definitely is some some um
positives and i think it's really
important um
in an industry that we are just to
acknowledge you know how fortunate we
have been through this
um like broadly i know there's
definitely people in the games industry
certainly on the journalism side which
especially if you're potentially
freelance for some people
i know have struggled because there is
maybe less budget out there
and more investigatory pcs right now
but hopefully that will come back but
yeah broadly feeling
pretty fortunate even though it has been
a challenge yeah definitely i feel like
you know it has strived in our cases
gaming is just more than sitting in
front of a tv
especially now as all of us you know we
work in the industry so there's been
other ways to kind of make it more
innovative
you know give the advice to those who
are not used to doing things digitally
anymore
you know so yeah this is like everything
you guys have said i totally agree on
and that's something you know i've been
implementing as well from my own
you know platform so for someone
starting out
you know in the freelancer contracting
world in the games industry
how can they prep how can they prepare
themselves for the next generation of
gaming
how can they be ahead of the game
i think it's i think for me um
first of all just making sure that
you're visible so
you know i think lots of people you know
they they love games and then you'll see
a job come up say on twitter or
somewhere and they'll reply and say
i don't have a portfolio or i don't have
a blog or i don't but like i really love
games i'm really
excited to write about them and it's
like well you need to have stuff
somewhere you know for me i think
that's really important particularly as
you know gaming is
is becoming ever more mainstream more
and more people want to
to do this you know they want to get
involved so you know whether you want to
make games whether you want to write
about games whatever you want to do
you know you need to have your work out
there you need to be constantly
writing you need to be making sure
you're staying up to date you need to be
putting that stuff somewhere that you
know
if i put a job up you can send me it
straight away and be like here's what
i'm doing
you can see you know the recent work
i've done i think that's really really
important because
you know as we move into this next
generation there's going to be a really
big push to bring more people into
gaming and so
you know what if you're already here
start making a name for yourself for
yourself now i think that's really
important
and then obviously you know as we move
into next gen you might feel a bit kind
of pressure to
buy consoles to have every console to
make sure that you are kind of um
in terms of technology you know ahead of
the curve and i don't necessarily think
that that's
you know hugely vital i'm sure we'll
touch on this later in the panel but you
know i do think that actually
something we see particularly in games
journalism is you know
it's about having a different
perspective or finding an interesting
angle and you know we still have
articles that are written about games
that are a decade old that are two
decades old you know so it's about
honing your voice in your craft it's not
necessarily about you know making sure
you're completely
technologically up to date you know it's
about making sure you're just building a
body of great work and then
you know maybe someone will send you a
console for free
fingers crossed playstation
um so for me i think
i i think from the brand perspective for
the next generation of gamers
like due to just internet access being
more widely distributed across the globe
um i think that gaming companies need to
prepare
for their market to not be so monolithic
um i think they need to prepare for
people who
are of all shades and all creeds and all
backgrounds
even more so than they are today to be
playing their product
and so i think brands need to start
looking at
um the democratization of a couple of
things
i think they need to look at the
processes in which
in which gaming operates because let's
not find some of the gaming the ways in
which
where in which the in game industry
works are kind of janky
kind of sun-time-ish sometimes like
contracts are here contracts are there
so i think that needs to be fortified in
in a proper way i think
that kind of niche feel gaming is not
niche anymore there's not five how many
five million five million gamers in the
world
yeah one of the millions i can't
remember which one but it is like so
many so i feel like there's so much to
do
when it comes to the next generation and
i'm not talking about consoles i'm just
talking about the next generation of
people coming into the industry
that needs to be looked at preemptively
before you know we continue on a path
where i feel like still we've got a lot
of work to do
um for gamers who are coming into the
next generation
or content creators or stuff i just feel
like a lot of people get stuck into this
kind of gamers entitlement
a lot of people do have to work for what
they do if you want to be better than
other people out there you have to
be determined you can't expect people to
come to you you have to do your pitch
decks you have to do your stuff you have
to be on people's radars
like lsa making sure you're visible
shoot your shot that's something i
always say to people
so i think the next generation the
market's
fastly going to change you know you see
esports uh
teams in in countries that you wouldn't
associate esports with
if depending on where you come from
obviously so i think
the next generation is just a lot of
variety
and i think the industry has to be
prepared for that am i going to buy a
next-gen console
yes am i going to buy it straight away
no i don't have that
money so i'm going to wait and see when
it goes down or maybe work with the
company for it but i think again
i don't think you need to get it
straight away i think there's always
issues anyway when you get it straight
away
i would say just hold off wait and see
what you like first i always say to
observe watch streams
and see what you like and then go for
the console that you like not what
everyone's telling you to go for
i think j and l have absolutely nailed
it and yeah like i said you've said
everything apologies i know it's it's
good it's great to hear
i mean just to i guess echo the things
that were most i think that were
particularly crucial to me but like
as al said absolutely everyone loves
games everyone wants to work in games
it's not enough you need to make
something
you know when i was at gainsbot for four
years i got my job by sending a video
i only once got sent a video in that
entire time for people i got sent emails
every day people wanting to
apply for jobs no one ever sent me a
video and i couldn't understand why
make something if you want to get into
the industry it doesn't matter what it
is as long as you're passionate about it
so you know and also that's kind of
links to find that angle
and whether it's in journalism or pr
whatever it is you want to get into
find that angle that is a bit unique and
special to you
and do that you know don't just talk
about it do it
but also talk about it it's important
too definitely i yeah i definitely you
know agree of all of you know your
points and everything and i feel like
the next generation is going to be super
huge you know is the tipping point is
going to be important not to just ask
people in the industry but those who
actually are
in the higher ups you know the studios
that you know the developers the
publishers
they have a lot riding on this and it's
just a thing of making things seamless
so everyone works together in unison you
know
so for gamers in general not necessarily
those who are in the industry
what are the few things you guys would
say to prepare you know for next year
in regards to budget you know in regards
to
you know how they can just i guess
sprucing up their gaming experience
so in terms of kind of budget obviously
there's kind of very straightforward
tips there so
luckily the thing about the games
industry is that we'd love to make a big
noise about our consoles going so
there's no kind of
surprise launches you know for a very
long time that they're on the way so you
could start you know if you
already know which one you're interested
in or whether it's both you know you
kind of start putting money away
you can start you know kind of reducing
your spending where possible that kind
of thing however
how it was best for you to save um i
think in terms of kind of preparing
preparing for the next gen i think it
you know if you're looking to kind of
spruce up your your gaming experience i
think that actually
in a year like this we tend to see you
know um
game releases big game releases aaa kind
of prestige titles
starting to slow down a little bit you
know we don't have as many big titles
coming out but what we do have
is loads of little indie games that pop
up in in the space left behind you know
so there's lots of
really great experimental titles that
you could go out there and play it's
actually a really great chance because
you know all the studios are working on
these you know their big ps5 titles
their big xbox series x titles
and so actually you know there's there's
there's more space for these games that
maybe you wouldn't have discovered in a
normal year perhaps you'd have been
playing something else
so you can kind of go out and track
those down it's a really great chance
for you to
find really little indie gems that you
wouldn't have played before
or just to go back and kind of revisit
the generation you know that that we've
had i think it's been really fun
uh you know there's a a really great
writer called vixx and she recently
wrote about
how you know everyone's been comfort
gaming uh
in in this period of time and i think
that's exactly i've been going back and
and replaying old favorites
really kind of falling in love with them
again and so there's kind of lots of
different things you can do to
to prepare yourself to kind of rethink
about the
um re-experience this generation before
we go into the next one so you really
feel what's different about it you
really appreciate the jump that we're
about to make
um and then like i said yeah just kind
of vary what you're playing go and have
as many experiences as possible
particularly if
you're if you're keen to get into the
industry then that's something you
should be doing anyway you should always
be kind of looking outside the obvious
but
this year is a really great chance to do
it there's really great indie gems out
there for you to find i completely agree
i found some really great indie gems
um that i've been playing and i feel
like indie sometimes come out with the
best new ip anyway
because uh i do find that a lot of
triple a you know prestige
publishers they tend to release the same
thing
over and over again and i get tired so i
love having some new ip i think it's
great and i think indie is
the next step for that and that's why
you see a lot of tripoli publishers
working within the studios or
buying them out and stuff like that i
think it's really great i don't think
you need to break the wallet for things
i think
there are always ways around things even
if you do it the very traditional
caribbean way get everyone to put money
in a pot and then
you you buy it out with afterwards and
you guys put money in the pot the next
month called a partner
like that's another way to do it there's
always different ways to do it i don't
think you need to break your back
and break the bank over buying a new
console i definitely think there's
different ways
yeah great tips um i think another thing
is there's lots of free
games more than ever there is high
quality free titles you can go and play
now
i mean okay you do need a console or a
pc initially so there is that cost
barrier to entry
but um you know there's so many free
games now i mean
i've spent probably more time playing
apex legends this year and i have
anything else to my shame and that's
free
yeah which is which is crazy and so
there really is options right out there
to
either play free games or you know as i
said revisit old classics i replayed the
original last of us and it's still one
of the best games ever made
in my opinion so um there's so much
there's so much out there
and i know and i know i'm much of uh
kind of sucker for this as probably
anyone with that feeling of wanting to
be doing
the new thing and playing that new game
but now is a great time to be like hold
on i mean there isn't that many new big
aaa titles coming out
you know maybe revisit indies as l said
or um
free games or or just go back and play
that game that you know you're always
like hey that's my favorite
now is a great time to replay it why do
you think
you know the transparency in a games
industry isn't as
transparent so i'm talking in regards to
jobs
finances opportunities you know ways for
people to you know i guess go into the
games industry
maybe the perception of gaming has had
added to that a little bit because um
i think if gaming was seen as less of an
insular niche
again quantum core underground industry
there'd be a lot more interest
in it a long time ago a bit more like
you know how fashion companies are now
trying to enter in all your pr and all
these different agencies
all trying to enter gaming because they
realized gaming was getting the industry
to not really lose chunks of money
during clothing
i think if there was an outside interest
interest before there would probably be
a bit more transparency a bit more
structure coming in but
um yeah everything that else said really
and truly i think it's a very young
industry
and unfortunately it's kind of adopted
against that lack of diversity that
um not i'm not saying heightened effort
isn't a bad thing but high levels of it
in an industry
which keeps out diversity is an issue
and so
i think just getting that structure just
like else said getting that
infrastructure but not losing that charm
not using that
fun um just
varied space where anyone can create
anything i think that's really really
key but
again it's a very young industry and
it's built itself from the ground up
really and truly
so yeah yeah
i don't have a lot to add because you
guys have actually nailed it i mean the
one the only one that i can really speak
to experience of is
is the fact that you know i moved down
from scotland to london to work in the
games industry because there was
nothing in scotland when i was yeah when
i was there now it's a bit different
like glasgow
it's a very creative city and there's a
few dead development studios there
but they're mainly indies and it's yeah
if you want to work in media up there
fat chance you know it's really really
difficult um so yeah it'd be great to
see some
um spreading around of the industry
across the uk i mean you look at other
countries in europe you know in france
there's multiple cities as paris there's
lyon
you know there's there's probably others
i can't remember but there but you know
in other countries there's usually at
least two places which are viable
um places you could set up and work in
the industry and that's one of the
things you know again to
fight back to covey this is hopefully
one of the things that might be our you
know very
small silver lining of this horrendous
event is that
it will hopefully encourage people to
not just all locate in london because
we're seeing
the negative effects of working in a
main city during a pandemic and it's a
really serious thing
so hopefully this can encourage
industries to allow people to work
all around to express themselves around
the country that can help bring in
you know local grassroots people into
the industry from those cultures
um because yeah i mean the games
industry in the uk is very white it's
very male it's very english
so um yeah we need to change that
definitely
definitely agree i feel like you know
going forward now
you know it should be a thing where
things things should now kind of
sprucing up especially because of how
things have been highlighted now that
everyone is home everyone has more
attention
you know in regards to what are the
issues and you know what can be done to
improve the games industry as well
so what are you guys excited about you
know
for the next generation of gaming
super fast loading times
truly like this is this is just what i'm
here for is yeah these are
super fast loading times that's that's
what i'm genuinely most excited about
you know i was
thinking about it the other day and i
was like i know i should be saying like
you know these expensive new worlds and
this but it really is you know
i'm very little things well genuinely as
somebody who plays you know both across
pc
and console you know in particular this
next generation of consoles you know the
difference is really stark
in terms of loading time so you know
when we saw some complete
some of the footage um particularly
saying the ps5 uh
state play it was just incredible they
were like just you know that was the
loading screen and i was like
wow
yeah i will play anything if you promise
me like a two second loading time like i
think it doesn't matter what it is
knack three okay let's do it like you
know
so i'm very very excited about that um i
think i'm also just really excited for
uh
kind of the the potential of playing
games anywhere at any time you know
we've
not quite nailed it yet obviously we've
got a stadium and that's kind of not
taken off perhaps as they hoped
um and you know and and things like kind
of playstation now again
still not had quite the level of pickup
though that they would like
um although i did play playstation now
on the beach uh which was like
incredible
but you know i think that's kind of what
i'm really excited for because i think
this idea of having you know
we're still not quite there i think
xboxes is definitely the closest
but a netflix of games is you know i'm
really desperate for that because i'm
somebody who
you know i love to come for game i love
to go back and play games over and over
i play
something different kind of a lot and so
the idea of just being able to kind of
pick
through and just pick it up wherever you
know play on my phone
play it on my laptop you know go and get
into bed and play it there you know that
kind of thing i'm really really excited
for that and so
a lot of it relies on the internet
infrastructure and that's difficult
because you know that's not really under
anybody's control but i'm really excited
for the steps we're taking in that
direction
and also just how much that kind of
opens up the games industry because i
think one of the things i find really
interesting about games as an industry
is that we unlike say
say you wanted to get into films um you
wanted to get into television
and they people said oh there are these
classics you should know that really
inform
how people have created film how people
created television you know you can go
back and watch them
you are most likely going to be able to
find them somewhere online you can go
back you can get involved
games that's really difficult to do you
know somebody you know now if you're
talking about saying
something like castlevania symphony of
the night you didn't play that
originally you know and you're not and
you're somebody who's new to games
do you know about emulators i mean i
know
it's difficult because that's what you
kind of have to do we we have
really terrible um heritage protection
in our industry we don't protect you
we've got the national video games
museum um we're doing really great work
trying to
to to protect our legacy but we don't
have that and so if you want to come
into our industry now it's actually
really difficult to play loads and loads
of games are you going to go and buy
every console there ever has been and
buy all the games for it so i love this
idea that actually as we start to bring
these online
what you could just do is sign up for
xbox game pass what you could just do is
sign up for playstation now
and then you can play all of these
classic titles that you really need to
know and have played and experienced
to to be successful in this industry and
so i think it's actually going to be
really great for democratizing
you know entry into our industry you
know that's what i'm really excited
about so fingers crossed that like the
internet instruction gets sorted
just a tiny little ask so that we can
really you know use that kind of
streaming potential
um you know to it's to its full
potential
i've said potential twice there
she's making sure she doesn't repeat
words to me yeah
no i that was going to be my point like
literally the next 10 million gamers are
coming from
the african continent from south america
according to a study that i
recently read so that democratization is
very very key
we shouldn't all need to shut up you
know a couple of
hundred at least um to to to access
games and to be able to play games i
think it's really really
key to do so and that's why i said
companies need to prepare for that they
need to also
enable that to happen um so i am excited
about studying that happening i
know like you said it hasn't taken off
as well yet but i think that's because
also the people who they're launching it
to are still
very privileged in what they have so
they don't need it
like right now when we get that access
to
other places um which is happening now
but then you probably see a different
different maybe an uptick a later uptick
in that
but um the next thing i'd be really keen
for for the next generation it's just
new ip
i love new ip i'm always keen about
diving into different worlds
different i i know ever since i opened
my big mouth and started talking there's
been a lot of black women on the screen
and i'm
happy about that but i'd also like to
see that mirrored elsewhere
more asian women more native women yeah
well you know just
different people on screen different
stories on screen i'm sick of medieval
stuff i'm honestly tired
i'm so tired of medievals and dragons
and don't get me wrong i love a fantasy
game
but you know when it becomes repetitive
and you see it in 500 different
iterations and you're like
so why can't we set this in ancient
china and why can't we set this in
cambodia why can't we set this summer up
you know i want people's imaginations to
go beyond
to research what they you know to go
beyond that um
and also with the canadian native uh
community i love that game
that is one of my is it beautiful it's
so amazing
um it's so educational and i want more
of that on a mainstream
um as well so yeah i'm just excited for
those kind of things new and it doesn't
have to be
set in the cultural uh earth world like
just new iv new different
new stories new imagination i think
we've gotten stuck in a rut within
gaming you know where it's franchise
franchise franchise
but i would love to see some new things
come out and i think we saw it recently
with um
the xbox um game showcase a couple of
new ip that are coming out like medium
actually got me excited but
yes more stuff more stuff that's what
i'm looking for yeah too yeah i
completely agree and i think um
a particular kind of bugbear for me is
the fact that i think over the last few
generations
it's really all been about kind of
graphical capability and how pretty we
can make these games look and i'm hoping
now we're hitting that kind of threshold
where
pretty much everything looks great we
just agree that those games look amazing
now
so maybe we can focus on story i think
storytelling is that aspect of gaming
which is still lagging behind uh overall
there are some great examples you know
again i'll say the last of us remastered
i think that's the finest storytelling
i've ever experienced in a video game in
terms of like creating real characters
that we can that we can relate to um so
i'm hoping that maybe in this next
generation fingers crossed we can put
storytelling front and center in in the
aaa like i know lots of indie games do
some fantastic storytelling i mean more
of the
like the hollywood of gaming to kind of
shift that focus from the you know the
particle effects
to the personality effects the
storytelling yeah
um that's what i'm excited for yeah
definitely agree i just hope that
everyone
in the industry has taken heed taken
everyone's advice
you know just to ensure that we do get
the very best you know
kind of 12 and more into not just making
it look pretty like you said
but going more into the story driven
stuff making sure there's more extra
because people are paying for games at
the end of the day
they want to make sure they're getting
their money's worth you know and last
but not least
your predictions for gamescom were you
guys excited to see
what are you expecting my predictions
again so much
i don't really know i feel like that's
what i'm kind of excited about this year
is that
you know i don't really know what's
coming it is a really weird year it's
been a weird year just in terms of there
being no events you know it's been
really strange to not
be out of the country every month you
know and so you know because we are
seeing
these really huge final prestige titles
that blow everything else out of the
water
yeah i'm really intrigued to see you
know what's new
that's kind of trying to as i said
before fill that space that's been kind
of left behind in between these
big kind of chunky releases so i'm just
basically i guess i
i want something new it's been mentioned
before kind of new
ip and i think that's that's what i'm
really excited for i think kind of one
of my favorite games this year has been
go sashimi
yes which oh my god i can't stop playing
it's still the best thing i've ever
played i've got a little bit like loopy
as well because i've started to feel
like photo mode is happening in real
life so i genuinely saw like some leaves
blow off a tree the other day
and i was like no i'm outside in the
real world like
i could just change the time of day
oh we're outside like okay um but that
was kind of a game that obviously we've
known it was coming for a while but it
was a bit of surprising that it was just
something completely new it's not based
on anything it's you know and so i
that's kind of what i'm looking for
particularly because that for me has
been another game that
um it's kind of controversial because
people are going both ways in it but for
me i actually found the storytelling
really incredible
and there's a moment in that i can't
school for anybody but it's just a tiny
little moment a tiny little side
random occurrence that happened that was
like one of the best things that's ever
happened to me in games and i think it's
because they've been
innovative they've tried you can tell
they really let their team
experiment and sometimes that felt a
little bit different but you know you
can tell there's lots of different
things where they've said
do an open world game but do something
really different with it you know find a
new way of you know how the ui looks on
screen
tell stories in a way that's surprising
you know do side missions in a way we
haven't seen before
and so i kind of want something else
like that i want something i think it
kind of echoes what you say cam
i want something with a big budget
because i do you know much as i adore
any titles and i play loads of them
you know i do love a big massive chunky
you know beautiful game
you know great particle effects so i
you know i want something like that but
that's really going to surprise me is
going to be really innovative so
yeah i guess that's what i'm hoping for
please
so i'm just going to echo what i said
before i'm just looking forward to
seeing you ip
um i don't know what i'm gonna see
and i don't mind to be honest as long as
it's something new different and
innovative i think that's my my hope and
my wish
i haven't gone looking into anything i
don't want to look i want to just be
taking in the show as it's presented um
and then see how how i feel about it
afterwards
i don't want to form any kind of
preemptive opinions
yeah i mean kind of similar but i'm a
little bit
melancholic about gamescom this year
because um what i've always loved about
gamescom is the
the the kind of it's what these are not
the mainstream games the
ones that are strangely big in europe
like simulation games you know they're
always huge in
europe and a big deal at gamescom and um
it's it's just a it's uh
of all the different um kind of global
events i've been to in gaming games
comes completely different
um it's and it's got that kind of uh
frenetic
weirdness that is just i don't know how
to describe it it's it's so it's sad not
to be there um
but um i'm and i'm also i i don't think
we're gonna see much new because
everything was pushed into these e3
replacement um presentations that we saw
so i'm a little down on it but hopefully
i'm gonna be wrong hopefully there's
going to be something
vague and exciting and you there for us
as well definitely
thank you guys so much for you know
being a part of this panel
cam j l it was a pleasure to be
talking with you guys and i hope you
guys enjoy the rest of the show
[Music]
us people are coming here people are
coming here they're on a police station
one of them's only going to push one of
them's probably in that house
yep yep no
[Music]
hold on fire anymore
hate him this guy's pushing above i
think
no he's not that was you sorry
he just kind of go for a knife what a
fail
i don't even know why he would i have no
shields
i want to watch this one yeah i'm going
to run up this way
and try flat ground uh
i'm
yeah it depends
foreign
by the vehicle they were just camping
behind oh wow bruin i should have known
he's upstairs anyway
[Applause]
i don't hear anyone what was he doing
i want to leave here now i've got enough
um i'm going to take his brewing stay up
we're good you're good what position
people got bought back here as well
before
[Music]
[Music]
oh people come in here oh my god
[Applause]
there's someone above me
[Applause]
i got them
[Applause]
oh there's more people here
he's pinging me
okay i filter on the lid
[Music]
what scope
what
[Applause]
of these um no but
my teammates have i've been i've died by
it once
and i've got it clipped i'm waiting to
use that for oh yeah
that's so annoying i don't know hey
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
he's going to blue
cracked him oh i want to push but i
don't
but i do i mean you can they're not
they're not they're not
they're not ghosted
he's cracked he's cracked there it's my
pop smacker
come on come on come
did on kill him oh nice nice i'm trying
to get this guy here
he's pushing around oh he has to come
you're dead
oh come on
i see him he's here somewhere mark out
movie
watchdog
nice someone's in the phone popping yes
him
oh it might be his teammate below us
oh here he is he's up he's up top he's
up top
quick quick quick quick reload he's
coming
he's gonna drop down the stairs he's
through grenade careful
[Applause]
all right cool yeah yeah he's he's on
top he's on top um
nah nah i've got seven
i've got a gas mask so we can push up i
don't mind but we need to we're gonna
have to drop down quite quickly
uh should we just go down let's just go
down let's just get it on
he's getting shot he's getting shot from
from
from here i'm there becca i got moved
they killed him
[Applause]
above me
[Applause]
that's not the box okay you're good
there's any people up here
i hope there's no one to your left
that's the only one
yeah there is
[Applause]
where's the last guy
[Music]
there's another one there i think follow
me
[Applause]
[Applause]
hitting me up i'm running back a bit
i've just clustered it
[Applause]
it's nice hold on i'm coming back i'm
playing
[Applause]
boy i've got the other guy with the
cluster
oh no i just doubt myself at the cluster
oh my god they have their guns
oh someone's here oh no but that was you
sorry i'm just bugging out of him
[Applause]
nice
[Applause]
upstairs oh they are there well
oh we could kill them
[Music]
hi i'm i'm elaine i work on the games
and esports team in barclays ventures
and basically what i do is i look at the
best ways that
we can work with and support the games
and esports
uh industries um i've been in the bank
for a number of years but more recently
maybe in the last 18 months i've been
focused
completely on the kind of games in
esports space and in regards to
games i'm currently um trying to play uh
call of duty on a mobile on my mobile
mobile my mobile phone
that's me natalie perfect and i'm
natalie o'giver i'm the law tech
ecosystem manager
at our physical sites in national gate
and so day to day essentially i look
after
a formidable amount of law tech startups
connecting them
with our law tech partners and through
mentoring and
um events and as well as that i'm also
part of the black professional forum
leadership team so
looking at how we can make sure that
we've been a more inclusive network
and supporting our black entrepreneurs
and colleagues in parking spencers
and on the side um i am uh
not a big gamer but i must admit i do
have battles with my boyfriend on the
xbox so
a lot of the time i will play gta um yes
that's a little bit about me
amazing so you know we're here with
gamers
essentially and it's really nice to have
you guys i was super excited to say
yes barclays games are here and i
stumbled across you guys when i was
trying to plan an event and i was
looking for
banks um just you know kind of banks to
work with especially for this event
and then i saw barclays games i believe
i saw you guys when
you guys were working with platform and
i was super intrigued and super
interested to see you know what you guys
do how you guys
fit into the games industry so i wanted
to just ask you know
essentially what is barkley's games what
is the goal and
you know how you guys have been
navigating through the games industry
yeah sure absolutely yeah it's really
interesting so the part of the bank that
we work in
is called ventures and the kind of remit
of our team is to explore new
opportunities
for the bank um and we've been working a
number of years
a team devoted to creative technologies
um
and the creative technology sector and
we felt that there was definitely more
that we could do in the games in the
esports space
and then so we we spent a lot of time
kind of researching and understanding
the industry
um and we felt that it was appropriate
that we have a team that's solely
committed to these industries
so we set up a team back about 18 months
ago
and you know what we're trying to do is
you know we've
spoken to you stephanie before about how
we try to you know
learn about the sector learn about what
people and businesses are doing in the
space and then looking at how we can
support or actually help the sector um
to kind of help it propel particularly
in the uk as well
it's amazing it's great because you know
with gaming and just with the games
industry essentially
it's not just jumping in you know it's
education it's learning about
you know because everyone knows now that
the games industry is very popular
it's now i believe it's even more
popular than the entertainment industry
especially
from a lucrative standpoint so i think
everyone's trying to pick all their way
into seeing okay what can they do for
the games industry but
you know essentially the most important
thing is to first learn learn what you
can do
exactly exactly and one of the things
that you know
we really pride ourselves on is trying
you know we know that we have to be
authentic in doing this the last
we is kind of wade into this sector as
a large non-endemic um and try and you
know just stick our name in different
places what we want to do is actually
actively
show that we deserve um you know the
the right to be able to work in this
space and that we actually do give back
and support
this is it this is it actually is
anything you want to touch upon
in regards to where you know you fit in
regards to diversity inclusion because
that's
one big thing for me when i started nay
saga
no 100 and and what's interesting is um
me and and some of the guys from the
gaming industry are kind of looking at
you know where we are seeing lack of
diversity this is them and
i think the the key thing is kind of
matching up with
organizations that are really kind of
out there and instilled in that space
and so we've done a kind of a lot of
conversations and
and sponsoring a lot of work in terms of
those those diversity groups that are
really kind of combat in that space but
just kind of externally as well and
you know past games a little bit we're
looking around how
can we develop entrepreneurs how can we
help them grow because
there's kind of a massive um piece of
work that's kind of come out around
how uh black founders in in specific
um have kind of less access to networks
less access
to mentors so we're kind of looking at
in our space how can we support that so
without saying
too much because there's a couple of
things that's coming up in this space
um it's something that we're kind of
looking towards and
actually creating tangible programs in
that
and i think that's where the difference
is is not just saying oh yeah we
recognize the changes what can we do
to make that change different and
actually see some tangible difference so
yeah i think i would say it's for me as
you know
as a black woman it's definitely a long
pro
progress i think you know stephanie you
would agree but
we're seeing some change we're seeing a
lot of people talking about it now and
you know
not being afraid to to have these really
awkward conversations
um so i think that's a really kind of
powerful stance so
that's that's kind of what i would say
on that uh without giving away too much
yeah because you know change isn't isn't
an overnight thing
and you know the small steps you're
seeing it is making an impact and
going back and watch you know what you
said especially those within the black
ethnic minority
you know sector it's hard to kind of get
those networks
yeah no because what i guess we're not
put on that
pedestal you know we're not giving those
opportunities as
others and again it's just kind of
having that support system which is what
we need because normally when i started
nay saga
i didn't have a capital or anything like
that it was just literally out of my own
pocket and it still is out of my own
pocket but it's because i'm passionate
about it
and i know that what i want to do is for
the long term
and for people and peers after me so i
wanted to actually
touch up on when did you feel like it
was the right time for you know barclays
to now venture into the games industry
especially because
this is not now a really really good
time and being in a big corporate bank
like yourself
when did you guys decide like yep this
may be the time to
come down well it's an interesting one
because i think
being a a brand like barkley's we've
been in many
industries and you know we bank with
many industries but what
what we've kind of realized is whilst
working in the creative sector we need
more specialized
individuals and you know correct me if
i'm wrong i think that's kind of been
work that's been going over you know
especially the creative industry the
last
18 months yeah but um definitely you
know
we've kind of recognized that we do need
a hands in this space and and with that
you know like i said then you know um
elaine's also mentioned around the key
bodies that will help
provide us with those specialist skills
so it's something that we've kind of
been working on and you know like i said
we're in many industries as a bank
bank with many industries but we've
realized that we really do need a focus
in that creative sector
and that's kind of where the work like
this and we're having conversations with
you
and you know loads of different
organizations to help us get to the
place where we need to be
i think as well seeing over you know the
years the growth the sectors have you
know you mentioned earlier on it's
come you know it's bigger than the movie
and the you know the film that sorry the
movie in the music industry combined
you know we have to pay attention to
that and that's what we're doing as a
business is paying attention
into that and investing our you know our
time and resource to understand it
better
yeah no i definitely agree i feel like
especially because you guys have the
resources
you guys have the tools and the
knowledge i guess it's a thing of now
dwelling into something that can really
really help an industry that has been
i guess somewhat looked at as something
underground something kind of overlooked
especially because we've been on our own
for a long time so sometimes it's a
thing where you know
you know when you have like a baby or
you have something that you keep close
to your heart
especially with a lot of companies now
dwelling into he's just picking who's
genuine and who isn't genuine
who actually wants to help who actually
wants to see the long-term
effect of everything going on so
you know that being said about these
games and you know
eagle labs how do you guys plan to help
from a financial aspect
aspect especially going into the next
generation of console gaming
as you know as you guys are aware we are
now entering a new lifecycle of gaming
the ps5 is coming out the xbox series x
is coming out
new titles there's newer you know
developers
there's a lot of new emerging esports
companies and you know brands
content curators streamers how can you
guys
you know help and support from that
aspect
but if i kind of move away from that and
just talk about
eager labs a little bit in terms of you
know what we do in eagle abs because
it's very different again to
traditional banking um just to kind of
give you a bit of an overview you know
we we started off in in 2015
and it started from just a disused
branch base
and you know how can we connect with the
community in terms of business
entrepreneurs
providing them access to space mentors
and really over the last five years
that's massively grown
so i would say you know we've got 25
locations across the uk which is
absolutely
fantastic but in that not only do we
offer the co-working space and the
office space we
also offer you know access to really
emerging technology
including rappro prototyping and testing
which i think
it can be really difficult for for
business owners to kind of get in that
space and have that support where
it's okay to make a mistake and you know
we're here to help develop and
you know provide you mentors and access
to to a wider ecosystem
so it's interesting because you know
there's so much bits going on
a lot of people just see barclays as
just your traditional band
yeah as you know there's there's so many
different aspects
that we're supporting with so there's
there's various different ways but those
are kind of a few that kind of come up
to mind for me
so what has been barty's game's biggest
achievements so far
i think um for us as a team i think in
particular
one of the things that we set up within
barclays is the barclays games council
and what this consists of is members of
so so the bank is quite a large bank
with
services you know globally and what
we've done is we've set up the stance
from across the bank so you've got
representatives from all the different
parts such as
you know the ventures team which is us
you've got the investment
bank you've got the business bank you've
got the corporate bank you've got the
private bank you've got the consumer
bank you've got barclaycard
we've got representatives from all these
different parts of the bank
actually that we meet quite regularly
and we discuss topics
insights and issues related to the games
and esports sector
and one of the things that we've been
doing as a team is trying to educate and
and
equip our teams within the bank with the
knowledge and experience that they need
so when they do
talk to whether it's a you know
developers or whether
it's you know peripheral or hardware
manufacturers or whether they're talking
to
you know influencers or they're talking
to esports teams
that they understand what the kind of
challenges that those people and
businesses face
yeah and also what they understand what
their goals are what's happening in the
industry what are the trends
and so that when they do go to work with
them and support them they're better
equipped and in a better position to
know what's right to do with them and it
just
makes for a much easier relationship and
i have to say the buy-in from these
teams
within the bank is fantastic and
enthusiasm for it
and people get quite excited about you
know and and
just the number of people who turn out
for the calls it's it's
fantastic it's it's really and that's
the bit which i really like is to be
able to see as a business
coming as one barclays to the sector and
looking at how we can best help and
support
i guess that's what sets you apart from
a lot of these
organizations and platforms is providing
that support
and you know getting people well
equipped in to go into the you know the
out world of the games industry
because you know a lot of the time you
know people are chucked into the walls
they don't know what to do or how to
navigate you know within the games
industry because it's such a huge space
and i really like how supportive bark
these games have been
so far especially in the space of i
think it's about two three years you
guys have started or
about 18 months that we've been wow
we've looked at creative technologies
for a number of years yeah
and back from the 80s i think but in
particular and you know we've always
worked with businesses in the games and
esports space i think it's just
particularly our team being established
you know and some of the other you know
some of the other things that
you know i talked about how our team
you know one of the things that we
really pride ourselves on as a team as
well is that we actually listen to
what's going on and then
coming earlier on about listening to
what business is trying to achieve what
their goals are and what are the kind of
issues and problems or pain points that
they have and how we can work and help
them with those
you know and some of the activities that
we've done recently
um will reflect that so for example um
uk gains industry have a slack channel
that they use with i think almost like 3
000 members to communicate with each
other
industry related um topics um
and i think pre covert they'd often have
a lot of face-to-face meetings or
catch-ups and what happened obviously
with covert
but being that in a bit that sorry it
was an inability to actually
reach sorry to meet face-to-face so what
we did is
we paid for the upgrade of the slack
channel that they used that meant that
they had more functionality more tools
to be able to communicate and work
together as a community
and we were happy to kind of support
that to help with you know for the uk
industry
we're also doing you know we're members
um and again
i think we're probably one of the only
um thanks to a member of
yuki we're a member of game republic
women in games
uh tiger were members of fame games
where
people of color um out making games
so what we've done is actually i'm
working with all of these trade bodies
is actually learning from them as well
and actually helping them as well
promote what they're doing
so recently natalie and myself um have
been going out and interviewing senior
members from these
trade bodies in a kind of a series of
content videos that we're doing called
meet the industry
and then what we're doing is is pushing
those out through
our social media channels as well to
help promote what they are doing
um and then also as well we
um i think one of the things for us as
well is to try and invest in grassroots
activity
so you may have seen earlier this year
we were presenting partners
or presenting presenting partners for uh
uklc
uh for the summer split which just
finished uh
monday um and then also as well
we are kicking off a sponsorship with
nse so the national students esports
uh for the academic year 2021 so that's
quite exciting um
you know that that all starts to really
i think come to life with you know the
the um a-level results coming out
um i think it's next week again in the
space of 18 months you guys have done so
much and
really helped those with you know
existing platforms and organizations
some of them
a lot of people would have recognized
you know people of color which are
really good friends of mine
and it's really good to see that you
know you guys are
doing your bit to really tackle on what
the problem is and how you guys can you
know be the help and solution
and again you guys can always be members
of naysagar
always welcome always welcome i think
you know
the thing is as well which i didn't
mention is that i think
all of the way that we're doing this we
hope that it comes across that it's
authentic
because that's really important to us
because our team are all quite
passionate about the industry in the
sector
um and we're very careful of how we
approach things and
how we present ourselves so it's really
refreshing to hear from you as someone
who's so you know embedded in
in this industry to get that feedback
from you so i appreciate it
we appreciate hearing that oh honestly
it's fine because again i wanted to make
sure that
people know what barclays games are
doing how they're helping you know the
community the industry
and making sure that it's not i guess a
pr stunt
or it's something of now and then people
are just forgetting about it later
because
but you know we're slowly starting to
see who was real and who was fake and
it's good to see that there's the
ongoing work
happening with you guys and that's why
i'm really excited to you know have you
guys
within this panel and really dedicate
this time to learning more about
barclays games and people who are
watching how you know
they can really look about you know
finding you guys and seeing what you
guys are always up to
and then i wanted to go into like what
are you guys doing to prepare for the
next generation in gaming
you know again how are barclays game
preparing themselves
in terms of you guys looking at the
markets are you guys
seeing you know where
i guess communities can work with you to
prepare yourselves again like you said
you guys are listening you know to the
community listening to the industries
but
how are you taking on that feedback and
working your way and preparing your way
to be fully well equipped
into the next generation of console
gaming because again september's around
the corner
there's a new lifecycle in gaming and i
guess
yeah just wanted to know from that
aspect you know what have you guys done
are you guys even
getting yourselves a ps5 an excellent
series x like you know what you guys
doing
you know we've we've been doing a lot of
kind of you know i suppose
like everyone else this year has been a
really interesting year hasn't it yeah
in regards to how you know particularly
around you know the different different
events that are happening and not
happening
um i suppose it kind of keeps going i i
probably sound like a broken record but
we do
just it's that kind of listening and
talking to people so talking to
different publishers
talking to different hardware
manufacturers and
you know keeping our ear to the ground
and also then using you know the
relationships that we have with all
these different bodies as well because
you know all these different groups that
we're members of as well are entrenched
in this industry as well and talking to
them about what they're doing what their
plans how are they evolving how they
you know particularly as well with this
year with combat how are they reacting
to the way that they would normally hold
events and activity
so yeah i think it's important that you
know it's like i said earlier on it it's
about listening and
you know to the different groups that we
work with the different bodies you know
having our ear to the ground
it's um you know we rely on on on our
trade partners so that the uk
the game republic women in games people
of color to actually see what's what's
what's happening in their space
understanding as well what insights they
have
about trends or developments um and also
then talking to the different
organizations who are
you know in the heart of it talking to
publishers talking to manufacturers
talking to streamers talking to esports
teams as well on a very regular basis
and i'm watching how they evolving and
then seeing to make sure that
that us and our team within the bank are
able to address that and to be able to
to help them as they evolve
nice nice and natalie does anything
maybe you yourself personally
from aspect from the diversity side
especially trying to include more black
people of color how are you and your
you know from your standpoint how are
you preparing yourself with them
in terms of the next generation of
gaming um
so if i think
my my role is more so in in terms of
ventures and i'm connecting in with the
gaming piece so if i just go into like
what we're doing
in benches and eager labs yeah yeah
entrepreneurs
and so in in our space is quite
interesting because we've been um
again doing a bit like you guys having
the conversations with the groups are
actually embedded in these communities
and
really listening to what they want and i
think you know i touched on it very
briefly earlier around
um you know again with black founders
it's around the
um the lack of access to mentors
lack of access to funding and kind of
that network
so um again without saying too much you
know we've been working on a program
specifically for black founders
um and kind of combating some of those
difficult pieces and
you know engaging with them and giving
them you know the the
the focus i think is is what's necessary
i think that's really what's kind of
come out
of everything this year with george
floyd
um and you know even using the word fame
and and you know separating that is
we need to be able to have a focus on
the communities that are really kind of
being impacted um and you know this year
is definitely been shown that from time
to time again you know the black
community whether that's through covered
19
whether that's through child birth and
i'm kind of going off tangent a little
bit but
that community is always kind of
severely impacted so yeah
there needs to be a focus and we need to
really shout about it so
again without saying too much because we
have a press release coming out really
soon
all excited we have a program that's
kind of dedicated to supporting black
founders on a journey
um and you know we partnered up with an
external company that
is in the community and black founders
themselves a non-profit organization
that's been running for the last three
years that is there to help
the next generation of entrepreneurs
getting them in that kind of ecosystem
of people that
are decision makers that that you know
have the funding connects and you know
that can develop your build um your
business around
hiring good people and xyz so it's been
um for me personally as you know a black
woman being
in a organization like what i'm in it's
been an amazing journey it has been also
a tiresome journey but i think
this year um i missed kind of everything
that's going on we've
like you said seen who's really standing
for us and and
who's just kind of here for
the moment yeah and and again to kind of
go
back to elaine's point it's around we're
trying to make sure we're doing
something tangible and not just saying
we're here because it's something that
is
topical um so you know i'm really
excited for you know the program that
we're going to launch but also
connecting in with
with elaine and like i said we've had a
few different conversations with a few
other organizations
in and the gaming world that are kind of
combating diversity and inclusion
and crime again creating that space and
that platform to say there are people in
this industry
look at what they're doing um so yeah i
think you know
we're seeing the beginning of something
beautiful um
to say i think it's you know it's not
going to be something that's quick
um but we don't want it to be quick we
want it to be comfortable we want it to
be long lasting so
you know i'm i'm excited for the end of
this year
uh without saying too much what it's
going to look like
next year and again year on and year on
because
just about us it's about the next
generation that's in school
and that are thinking you know i might
not want to go down a traditional route
i
want to become an entrepreneur in this
space and you know i see people that
look like me
that are in this space and do really
well and i think that's that's what it's
about and you know
excited to see where where we get to but
definitely again it's about those
tangible
programs and actions yeah i think it's
very very important because again
you know we're not so physically seen
in terms of the games industry which is
why i started nay saga because
five years ago when i wanted to get into
the games industry it was super hard for
me because again
it's like the games industry is you know
it's a bit of like um
what do you call it like a school you
know there's the little clicks and stuff
yeah
i guess if you don't know the most
popular person um
then it's a very hard time for you
especially with the industry for being a
very white male dominated space
so i just you know thought i create
something to
set myself aside so when the doors do
come knocking i'm in control i'm in
power because
i am now in a space where i'm able to
help my people help my community
and in doing so you know working and
like speaking to you guys allows
my community to understand that there's
an existing organization that are
willing to help
do stuff with a long-term process and
especially being a black woman is hard
like you said it's tiring there's times
i just don't want to get out of bed but
i know that
my mission is bigger than you know
me getting out of bed and everything
like that you know especially the next
couple of months are very very
crucial and it's what will set the time
for next year and years to come
yes that's really good that you guys are
working super super hard and
again it's an honor to have you two on
the panel
you know discussing how important and
you know what barclays games is
for my audience and i wanted to kind of
end it on
what are your predictions for gamescom
what games are you excited to see like
but it's really it's it's a weird one
this year isn't it
i think yeah i was planning on going but
yeah i mean like this time last year
i was there you know yeah i went last
year you know and the team went as well
the games team um
it was fantastic you know it was my
first i've been to some events but to
actually not been to gamescom
and this year it's all going to be done
virtually so yeah
yeah it's going to be interesting um
but i think as well you know it's again
it's also interesting in the fact that
you know we know e3 this year
um and e3 is normally an event where we
get those you know those big
announcements
yeah yeah exactly exactly there's no
keanu reeves this year
[Laughter]
we'll see with november so i think you
know and
the consoles you know have made they're
kind of you know over the last month or
two
you've seen the consoles reveal they're
kind of their big games yeah
um i think you know we're just trying
everyone's just waiting to find out a
little bit
more about the actual consoles
themselves
um and i think that's you know and that
that for me
will help me decide which one i'm going
to buy or do i need to buy both
i don't know yeah um so so
it is i find it really hard because i
was thinking about this question
prediction game wise it's really hard to
pick
what it's going to be because it's such
a peculiar year different than any
way it would run one of the things that
we are
i suppose one of the things that we're
quite we're um quite happy about is the
sponsorship
that we have just done with yuki for the
uk game show sorry the uk
game of the show of the show yes my
friend
yes and so basically there is i think
there's like 15
teams have from the uk have put their
games forward
and to represent the uk in a competition
then that will be brought through
to um to meet against international
games
that's amazing because my friend is
actually hosting it mr midas
that's right yes i'm excited to see how
that goes and it's a i really like the
concept of it
so it'll be really interesting to see
how that plays out and it's really good
again
barclays games you know involving
themselves in such an
incredible innovative event like that so
yeah that's crazy
yeah what are your predictions natalie
well this will be my first one
so i'm gonna be a complete newbie so i'm
actually just
excited to see how it goes um elaine's
kind of gave me loads of fuzz stories
and so yeah i'm just excited to view and
just just see what's out there really
nice i think it's i think it'll be
exciting i like to be from your
standpoint as well being new to the
whole gamescom you know
sphere seeing what's there seeing all
the announcements
and yeah like it's again it's really
cool to you know especially you you
haven't
been there last year so to see the
transition from
being on the floor to now seeing things
virtually maybe this may be the thing of
the future
everything's now probably being moved
virtual and again things are doing
things
seamlessly so it'll be really really
cool to see you know how
gamescom pans out so yeah what's quite
nice about the virtual pieces it makes
it more accessible
yes because not everyone can go you know
travel to cologne
um in germany so to the ability that
they can actually view it online and you
know see the announcement there
you know i think you could always do
that but i think that everyone's all in
this kind of same boat together it's
quite nice
yeah that's true i like the
accessibility of things and again
it's really good that everyone now you
know is able to see everything
so yeah but thank you so much for your
time it was
absolutely amazing and honored to have
you guys on this panel
where can people find barclays games
yeah um so
yeah please i'm elected and this is one
of the things that you know as i said
earlier on we like we're listening
and we like to talk to people and find
out what's happening in the industry
so um yeah definitely you can get in
contact with
us via um our email and
mark sorry games at barclays.com or
visit our website games.barclays um
and then also as well you know we've got
we're on twitter and we're on linkedin
so barclays games just just check us out
and you know you'll see any of our you
know upcoming announcements
or activity and we're pretty active in
in the social space
nice nice nice and i'm guessing the same
for united as well because you do more
of the
eagle labs yes so if if there's anyone
that's interested in eager labs and you
know what we do just go
on to our website and you can just
google
eager labs barclays or you can type in
labs.uk.barclays
and will come up amazing well thank you
so much for being a part of the panel
it was a pleasure and we will see you
guys shortly
thank you stephanie and thank you for
asking us to come on it's actually been
really lovely talking to you and
um i want to give out a special shout
out to girls in power
they are a network dedicated to women
empowering each other to be the best
support system
within all creative industries they are
an amazing initiative and i want you
guys to definitely follow and check them
out
they also do events workshops and
basically create things that help
each other within these spaces
oh hey this intro stay icy look at
talent
hey our phantom's pretty good
we have control of the objective defend
it
help me up pick me up
it's probably gonna get picked up though
all right i'm watching your dark right
now
damn someone picked him right back up
and he's probably gonna get right back
there
almost got another dart
oh snap oh they're about to take
they took the point
enemies are running low on
reinforcements
all right oh snap they're trying to take
the top i think
i got runner
killed him
i got 10 shots in the stand where
there's a lot of guns up there
like right here uh
yeah i'll take that thank you thank you
connolly
go here ronan we're on a gamer
45 seconds remaining
they're almost done i'm gonna flank a
little bit
all right i got ronin
someone pick me
he's almost done fema was lit lit
[Music]
done
oh look who's at the bottom look at
who's at the bottom
uh sir you know i had to i had to you
know
be the most valuable support player that
round but don't worry about it
you're more like a support npc had to
give you all some shine
couldn't steal all the thunder
this is the first time on uh striker
zone
that uh the point was on top for me and
forever
i'm flanking all the way around i don't
know if he'll pay off let's see
do you wanna try to get into this ulti
oh i need backup please stop from every
angle
damn didn't have enough time to recover
threw that one behind me
yeah oh
he's in my corner
there's a dude to the right of us
who is that
oh man it's too much to focus on at once
come on medic medic medic
trying to kill everybody in front of me
no i was talking oh yeah
yeah i know i don't know what our medic
was doing like he was just standing
still
we're out of reinforcement
oh you saved my life you're my hero
you're welcome
oh my gosh yo anvil guns
no clutch okay
oh man i couldn't take both of them no
i'm trying to snitch on them but my team
dag
wow they got bodied by one ronin
i hate to see it
and phantom's running like it's not the
end of the round already
oh god 10 seconds remaining
and didn't even get the leg shot changed
i wonder if it's still 80 to the leg
probably
you know i would have hit every single
one of them slacking bro
all right okay there ain't no slouches
over there we got this though
oh man look who went right back to the
top you know
light stuff uh no big deal you were
hacking
big facts
if i'm not at the top that means
everybody else is hacking
i'm gonna go like wide to the left
demos right
and i'm still not out at the top off of
that i got the most kills too
they work harder bro i'm working as hard
as a man could go
oh gosh they might try to
he's down here check out these kind of
plane they flanking
uh
okay they're over there with don vito
got him
oh i'm stuck oh this little thing right
this little nudge
literally just got me stuck they're not
rushing the point so we got it pretty
much
[Music]
they're out of life nah you're not good
enough
oh no no no no don vito
this is one thanks
45 seconds and this one
objective secured defend it tripled
first round oh man if i ever got my hand
on anvil's gun
ambrose gun is op it is bro i ain't
gonna lie it scares me when i see that i
i start like i duck in and out i don't
just shoot and shoot at that man
straight i duck in and out
he has way too much ammo for him
i'll be playing scared all right
we're going for the clean we're going
for oh nope it's not a sweet actually
this is
sweet no we lost one no
we're going we're going to call it a
sweep still i mean
try to do a flank get a quick kill yeah
and go put off
defend it i look their entire team up
oh yeah i got ambrose [ __ ] now
i'm gonna put a dart behind us so we
know they're pointing oh my back
my neck my back my neck and my back
oh
oh no
dag it was more than one uh dima and
oh wow they came in when i went to help
the other two
how they're posted up
oh my goodness what did i just walk into
oh goodness enemies are running low on
reinforcements
oh snap close the door somebody closed
the door i'm scared to close the door
it's not even gonna lie to you i guess
it's a man's job
i'll sacrifice myself oh come on
oh that anvil again i try to sacrifice
myself why does this medic
never have reinforcements yeah he never
has his uh he never has it
i don't feel like he'd be reviving us
sit down who do you think i am
keep it up
yeah i guess so i didn't even know
she's the last one yeah she last one
she's the last one
where'd she go
over here i don't think she hurt
defend it let's go
you had a few more downs because of me
because i threw up the alley with all my
traps and all those
positioning stop this stop the cap on
this
app i'm going to lead tactician when it
comes to this bro
the cap on
[Music]
uh yeah hi i'm charisse i'm 25 years old
i am
the community manager for the regions of
ptbr
at elgato i also am a video editor for a
streamer named elias
and i also stream myself i'm a partner
and before i even started working
at elgato i was a partner streamer i did
it full time
and then yeah i also
voluntarily help organize two charity
events which is speed souls marathon
and scotland nitro amazing
hi my name is michelle i am 27 years old
i work as a content creator and have
been doing so for the past six years now
uh i was born in the philippines raised
in sweden
and a big fan of health and fitness
i do a lot of charity work i've done
some with cherries as well yeah uh and
yeah big lover of animals and video
games
the best of both worlds so how did you
guys you know start your gaming career
you know and start working in gaming
all right so i it all started as a hobby
for me
i used to play video games growing up
with my brother
so before and after school we used to
play games together
and then i got i think it was in 2013 i
got introduced to twitch
and i thought it was a really cool idea
that i could share my gaming experiences
with so many
people from all around the world and
then it kind of just took off from there
um been meeting a lot of cool people
throughout these years that i've gotten
to know
and got in the work to getting the
chance to work with
it's amazing yeah i know like normally
everyone gaming again starts as a hobby
before
i guess the more you delve into it it
becomes into a career like myself
uh so i started actually i was looking
for
a job and i always played games in my
spare time after school so then what i
what i did is since i couldn't get a job
and i i also didn't feel like
doing nothing per se or like i was like
you know what
i'm gonna give the streaming thing a
shot
and then um yeah that's kind of how i
started streaming and then eventually i
started doing a lot of
charity streams and uh
that led me to participate in this
speedrunning event that's called
esa so the european speed running
assembly
and i was pretty much hosting
intermissions and then i volunteered to
do
their social media for a while and then
you know i kind of got the job i have
elgato right now because of that
um and uh it's also because i met
tom at the event and then we became
really good friends and once
this opportunity came along uh he
contacted me and asked if i was
interested in in in the position
and the rest is history yeah it's
hopeless pretty much
awesome just amazing shout out to tom
so i guess with that again it's just
kind of
naturally stumbling across and falling
into your career and i guess that
happens with a lot of people because
some people believe it's luck but
sometimes you just have to be at the
right place at the right time
more so i also think it's about um
you know sometimes when people give you
opportunities so like
all these different events that i got to
go to and even
a lot of the charity work that i've
managed to be a part of is because my
friend
morale which works at save the children
presented me with those opportunities
and then you know i
i did what i thought was right
and i put a lot of work into it so then
it led to what it is but there's a lot
of people that sometimes get
opportunities and they don't do anything
with it
yeah and then you know
the opportunities go away exactly so you
have to also put down
some work if you want to get somewhere
especially in the gaming industry i feel
like
a lot is volunteer a lot of people do
volunteer work
to start with and then they eventually
get the positions that they do
yeah some of the things is free labor
and although
people are not a big fan of it you know
i i do believe in an experience
experience really really helps you it
really you know makes you better
equipped especially in the games
industry because there's so much to do
especially you know you being a
community manager in you know your
region
so in regards to working with elgato
what do you you know look for
content creators streamers in regards to
you know being a partner well when it
comes to
being a partner at elgato it's not just
about
numbers although numbers are very
important
it's not only about that it's about also
like
having content that we like you know
it needs to be content that we find is
good
and we want people to represent our
brand
so they're going to be our ambassadors
and this doesn't necessarily mean that
like you
can't you only have to be family family
friendly
or that you cannot swear on stream yeah
that's completely fine really um
as long as people are having fun and not
being um
you know negative or
promoting harassment or bullying
none of that we don't tolerate that at
all that's all you know you want to make
sure
being a partner you want i guess be the
best representation for a big brand like
elgato
and mitchie you've been a you know
you've been a partner for the last five
six years now well like three to four
three three years yeah three years so
being a partner now
how has elgato supported you you know in
regards to
upgrading and just being the big brand
to just
you know support and back you um uh
i've been very fortunate to have been
working with delgado for so many years
they've supported me in so many
different ways
one of them being upgrading my setup
providing me with all these tools to
create my content
but i think the most uh also the
most favorite thing that i enjoy about
elgato is
that they always make me feel included
they give me feedback on the content
they that i create and they
even push it out on their socials as
well i
see how much time and effort they put
out
in engaging with community as well like
being on events
supporting charities and
yeah it's amazing to be a part of such a
successful company
that i feel genuinely wants to see me
grow
and wants to grow together definitely
i've definitely seen
how well they supported elgato myself
being a very new partner
just the the love and just embracing you
know a new content creator and like you
said
cherise it's not about the numbers it's
about how unique you are what you know
actually do
to kind of represent them as a whole and
i really do like how
again they've supported you over a
number of years you've spoken about
charities which are also important and
it's really very very also important to
understand that brands should be able to
do more than just talk
as you've seen over the last couple of
months there's all there's been a lot of
talkers you know but not a lot of doers
and i really really like how
elgato have really stuck by their guns
they've made sure that
i guess putting i guess my for myself
putting more black content creators on
and
more women as well as you know as a
partner
for elgato so that i really really
appreciate that so
for someone who wants to start out in
the games industry or may want to
upgrade their current setup
what would be the best and most cost
effective way to start off with
i think that sitting down and looking at
what you have to work with currently
and then working from that what do you
need in your setup
to create the content that you want
i remember getting a spare pc part from
friends that were upgrading the pcs
to make a streaming pc and then
buying a capture card that was what i
started with and then kind of
just working from that it takes time
stuff costs money so
uh you can do a lot with with the stuff
that you already have at home
i agree i mean i remember starting off
with the hd60
and like i've literally just upgraded
now but
it does the job you know quality over is
you know a real good quality product and
like you said sometimes you just have to
make do with
what you have but it's not i guess a
rush to get the best equipment
going definitely not no uh getting
second-hand stuff or just borrowing him
from friends to start off with
um and i think now you can even stream
from consoles as well if you already
have a platform
so there's a lot you can work with
before upgrading
but i would say the best product that i
did purchase was the capture card
because it gave me the opportunity to
cap
all all my different platforms that i
had
and for you michi what would be i guess
in regards to being cost effective what
did you start off with and
how did you you know excel into
upgrading your setup
uh i started with the capture card uh
and then
i got because i streamed on my xbox 360.
it was console gaming in the beginning
and
like i said i built a pc from what i had
i had a really old one
but i got a new cat a new graphics card
that i got put into the pc
and then i bought i've saved money to
buy a capture card
so that's kind of how i started and i
think i played like that
on a footstool for the couch on a tv
and then i had the pc hooked into the
console so i was sitting
really yanky and i don't know it was
it's the thing with growing it's so fun
to look back at where you started
yeah yeah you know just seeing the
journey of
where you was to where you are now and i
guess growing and
seeing what more you can improve on so
you know cherise how
are you especially as a community
manager and working for a big brand like
gato how are you guys preparing for the
next generation of console gaming
especially with you know the new ps5
coming out new xbox series x
like the mechanics and the specs that go
into
the console how would you guys be able
to support you know the newer consoles
and how would you be able to support
content creators going into the next gen
so
basically the new consoles are all going
to be
focused on this 4k hdr content
and basically what
we are we already have a capture card
that can provide
with that and i would say that
what people need to be doing if they can
is to upgrade their
tvs and monitors so depending on what
they're playing to support that
that 4k resolution yeah um but
regardless of the new generation
consoles like
1080p is still as a content creator a
very
popular resolution to go for for the
time being anyway
yeah no i definitely agree that's one
thing on my to do this
upgrading the monitor upgrading the tv
because again
things that we're going to be taking in
4k and it's always good to prepare
yourself
even even just being a gamer not
necessarily working in the games
industry as a streamer or content
creator
somebody who's just a game just a gamer
that loves such as game you know
i think definitely looking into like
investing in
better quality tvs and monitoring yeah
for sure especially
if they want to experience or have the
full experience
exactly definitely something they should
be doing gaming is definitely an
experience and i feel like it's
important to prepare for the experience
you know
what would be the beginner products that
you guys recommend
to those starting out uh
well i would say like a
general or specifically for capturing uh
in general maybe a personal favorite of
yours maybe something that
let's say they get that product and
they'll be good for like a good
couple of months before they purchase
something else so for me
one thing i probably recommend is i
guess the the hd60s
yes i was gonna say that yeah i
definitely recommend that it's
it allows you to experience the game in
4k resolution
uh but it was still recorded in stream
at 1080p
and that way it's also it's not very
demanding on your pc and
you get it's like the best of both
worlds really yeah um
a personal favorite of mine i would have
to say
is the stream deck i think the stream
deck and the green screen
so far have been like a big favorite of
mine especially because like i've moved
around a lot
yeah like country country wise oh yeah
i've moved like three times in the last
two years
wow and having the green screen has been
so helpful um because it's so easy to
just like
put it down put it up take it with you
it's honestly not not a huge issue
and the stream deck helps me a lot
because i do the video editing right
um and other things uh i use it for
streaming as well it's not like it's
just video editing
but uh i use it a lot when i video edit
and it's just a great tool to have um
in general i i don't think i can live
without my stream deck
you can teach me how to use the stream
deck i literally just
got it sent and i'm still trying to
figure it out but
so yeah there are a lot of uh i can i
can send you some
places where you can learn more about
the stream how to utilize it
uh i'd be happy to do that and guys that
are watching
we'll definitely link it down below as
well so you guys can actually have a
look on you know
how to use a stream deck and the most
easy beginner guide
giveaway so yeah we have lots of those
in our channel and sometimes
we also post it on social media uh so if
you happen to follow us on social media
you might come across like some nice
tips and tricks on how to use the
various
elgato products amazing and michi what
were you
uh you guys mentioned both of them the
capture card the hd60s
the external one that you can bring
anywhere
good for moving as well and then the
stream deck
the stream deck is like the whole
motherboard of the operation
i have control of everything my life
my mixer and just uh all the scenes in
obs as well
so just with the press of a button i can
easily just
do everything that would say that
and also can i say our third one yeah of
course
the more area a good gaming headset
uh it is as much as it is
important to upgrade your screens and
stuff
i feel so immersed when i play with the
kid with good sound
as well like getting into the feel so
getting into spooky games
uh definitely a good pair of headsets
yeah
definitely i would also say uh
get if you're gonna be creating a lot of
content and
in in general if you spend a lot of time
on your pc
invest in a good share like you're back
well thank you
in a couple of years yeah yeah i
definitely agree
i i remember i was using just like a
normal desk chair for ages
and just the difference between
upgrading from a normal chair to a
gaming chair
really helps especially if you're
editing playing games
all that good stuff and again like you
said streaming absolutely right
absolutely right but thank you guys
thank you so much i'm sure a lot of
people have learned and heard about
what elgato do you know how you know you
guys have been able to help
throughout the years you know the
perspective from a partner
and the perspective from a community
manager so what are your predictions for
gamescom
i am waiting for call of duty we haven't
seen
anything of the new call of duty yet
season five
came out for war zone but it's going to
be the last season right
yes and then yeah the new call of duty
i hope they will show some there i think
they will sure
yeah guys it has been an absolute
pleasure having you guys
on this panel especially just talking
tech talking from a woman's perspective
and understanding again the perspective
as a partner
and a community manager because i know
as a community manager
it's quite a lot you know to understand
the social levels to
you know talking with your clients and
fellow content creators
in terms of as well looking for by the
new ambassadors and partners as well
and then as a partner you know
maintaining that relationship that
consistency
and just i guess those kind of mutual
benefits as well so
thank you and thank you so much to
elgato as well for powering this event
and yeah guys thank you for having us
thank you for having me yay thank you
recently we announced our new long-term
partnership with elgato
elgato recognized how important the nay
saga community is
and how committed they are in working
with us within our gaming community
elgato have teamed up with us in giving
away the elgato stream deck
to one lucky viewer follow gamespot and
follow naysagar
using the links down below the win will
be contacted after the show
and this is an international competition
too so good luck guys
anywho g-bot that's what we calling you
right yeah yup
g-ball yeah hi team that's what you
rocking with
okay okay okay you got the orange too
see i can take your orange square that's
what's actually insane
which it could have it might actually
just how good at this game would you say
you are a scale of one to tender skill
uh i'd say about clean six and a half
seven months
okay i'd say the reverse but not the
reverse
the the obtuse because i'm like seven
seven and a half
eight on a good day that's what i'd say
that's when i'm not fighting my actual
friends who play this game back to back
i don't like them you know what bm means
[Laughter]
see i had to get in your head bro it's a
tactic hold up uh uh uh uh
so this is your main team this is a team
just messing with right now this is the
team i'm messing with
okay okay okay i see i just tried uh
gohan before but his combos my brain is
actually a little bit too smooth for him
can you stop that hey hey okay now i'm
getting mad
stop are you done all right peach
oh oh can't curse oh that's crazy sorry
about that
see normally i do play this stuff
because you watch my content like that
obviously right
yeah yeah i normally do swear right
before the uses of what this is going to
be for i got to be on my best christian
behavior
do you you curse a lot or are you just a
christian boy no i try and keep that uh
keep that sense around me at all times
plus i'm not the house true true true
coward i mean now i feel that foot it'd
be like that sometimes
so you're saying out the house like a
whole different person yeah it's
a language you know sometimes like you
know these
things might be considered sometimes but
you know so
you keep it like boondocks or futurama
in terms of cursing like you said crap
or did you but you're good
you're good afro you're not hearing me
you just oh
okay so one thing that that's good to
mention is my
internet right it does this thing to
where at nighttime it dips yeah this is
terrible
i can hear you fine since we're
recording but you're just not gonna be
like
be able to hear me it's terrible oh you
might not like what's gonna happen next
oh just kidding i dropped it that is
insane
what are you doing wow
see i never got in to go dude i could
never vibe with how clunky he felt
all right now you just pissing me off
yeah
you already got broly on your team bro
you're gonna do all this yeah okay
all right yeah you have to block me back
after this
it's fine let's find ready for this come
back stop stop
oh i fumbled the absolute back no stop
it uh
you gonna do something imma grab you yes
sir hold up
what bro i'm mad i don't really i like
that square you got and i'm trying to
level up off of it it's
nothing personal i think you could have
done that before maybe enough to do this
on me
i had to do it now i had to i waited for
this moment
come up no oh i shoulda i should have 2h
that i just looked at it and said that's
pretty
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no
okay so now that broly's gone i'm
feeling good
who would you say that is the best
character on the team that you got right
now that you know how to use
yeah even though it's kind of not
demonstrating it right now not outside
be like that you still got sparking
no you didn't i hate you all right i
might have you definitely getting
blocked
i'm just not sorry oh you didn't you
didn't why you you could have finished
the job what's good
i wanted to grab you i'm going to jab
you yeah yeah
hello you ready for it ready for it
oh i'd love to see it how you feeling
is it a seven six what's the scale like
let's get that [ __ ] up uh i feel like
it might be a six a six okay okay okay
we're gonna raise it up or you're gonna
keep it at six because i like talking
and right now i'm looking like what i
like to talk i'm just saying like you
gotta you gotta get it up can you do
better
huh i can do better okay let's go better
okay okay okay okay okay
see you can't let me keep on talking
trash like this i don't know about you
did you ever used to play like halo back
today uh
nah not really a group on a playstation
i didn't really get an xbox so it's
about 13.
and even then i didn't get xbox live
it's crazy how like how
it's tough it is right now because back
in the day having xbox was fired now
it's like if you have a playstation
playstation is like what xbox used to be
you really hate to see it
but yeah i used to play halo a lot and
that's i think my motivation for talking
mess like
people on there would just say anything
and i just had to say something back
if you don't yell when you do the attack
it's not going to do the same amount of
damage
i think the same damage regardless but i
i did not whatever you want you have to
really focus on the
the percentages you feel me you
all right broly left i'm not a fan of
broly personally
because it's super armor and you're
gonna try to do it oh you didn't
wow i'm sorry
i i am sorry oh hey
hello all right now i'm not a fan of
that too much
stop stop hey hey
okay
what am i doing
all right see this is this this is real
behavior
through behavior okay
okay i probably should have sparking but
i was looking at your sparking just like
them you don't like the color orange
that's insane
but i'd be like that'd be like that do
you uh do you play other fighting games
besides fighters or just fighters mainly
uh mainly just fighters i've kind of
backed off for like
tech in a street fighter attacking see i
tried to detect him but my brain is also
too small for that
i called the gohan brain problem there's
too many buttons
ow died yeah
okay you couldn't you were about to be
nice as hell now i see i see it
i see what you attempted
oh my gosh i should've just stand still
i'm a failure just kidding
oh what i did the wrong support and now
i'm paying for it
yes i no it's not
that that fabled seven i heard about huh
okay okay
i'm about to scream i'm about to scream
it's about to happen okay watch this
watch this you ready ready
so it's interesting because you said
golgi is your best you you think broly's
a better anchor though
yeah i feel like brother's better anchor
for me okay
i feel that i really don't vibe with
zebra lee is right here most of the time
he wants to super burly
i'm just trying to stray away from my uh
super broly because i feel like
he's just a little bit better i feel
that i feel that i know you're right you
spin i definitely agree with that
super only got like the sauce he broke
got the gorilla strength
like he makes those muscles mean
something
i'm sad it's fine what okay
i thought it worked all right i look at
the quick meet me
ready for it ready for it don't blink
don't blink don't blink oh i'm stupid
wait oh my gosh okay the fabled seven
percent
or seven out of ten is actually pissing
me off i don't know what the [ __ ]
the that was are you ready
uh i can talk about this i really mean
to do that that is fine i appreciate it
i'm stupid
hello hello all right i'm a little bit
upset
how many did you relax stop stop oh
yo i'm crying all right all right ready
ready i'll see you now you quiet now
i see you focused see you focused huh i
forgot you aren't sparking
oh no no
no please ready for this come back
all right that was good that was good we
have time for one more match
one more see now i feel like you warmed
up now i'm a little bit worried about
you i'm a little bit worried
but okay okay you you know that that's
the seat switch
you seen go uh sonic fox versus goichi
the
old joke i'm gonna need to switch seats
with you i'm gonna need you to cool off
real quick
get up bro i mean i'm feeling i might do
it on your chair you might have a better
life kind of chair for me
you know gaming wise so i might do
better if i'm in your chair so actually
you're right i'm gonna stay here
oh no okay now i'm upset hold up hold up
oh oh my leg oh my gosh
okay you definitely warmed up i don't
know who you are anymore i don't know
who you are hold up
hey
okay i'm out to be quiet too now
i need you to drop drop this please
thanks that's definitely dropped your
wish came true
oh my gosh i'll turn goku please
live we're going to bring buddy back
out hold up he's not getting all that
health back just a little bit of it
oh my gosh i timed that wrong i timed
all that wrong
really bro
oh i'm sad for you
hello stop it
right you'll go home he got so many
different kicks and like angles of
i i just i wish i could get good gohan i
just saw the patience
oh now i'm bad yeah yeah
yeah yo stop flipping damn
oh my gosh okay okay
okay okay yo you're go go take your
gogeta rather it's fighting like a
trunks right now i'm confused
i dislike you i think i genuinely
dislike you what the heck going on
hey yo okay okay i'm just playing the
game bro yeah you are playing
okay good stuff i can't be mad at this
let's go get a mix of me
oh my leg
all right ready for the crate just come
back at 20 20. hold up let's go let's go
let's go
oh you okay i'm looking at my hands like
where did i go wrong
oh my gosh okay
okay i just want to talk come here
thanks me
hey yo taco
okay hold up hold up hold up
oh you crazy i am
[Laughter]
it was a different level three maybe but
maybe on his
oh i could
oh oh you got me oh you
you had me no you got me
hey yo good game man that was great
good stuff
[Music]
so we hope you enjoyed the show we would
first like to thank gamespot for
partnering up with us
in hosting this event we would also like
to thank our amazing panelists
for joining us today for our very first
saving for the next gen show
we'd love to also thank elgato for
helping us with this giveaway
thank you to the rest of the nay saga
team for putting this event together
i'd also like to thank our graphic
editor for pulling these amazing
animations together too thank you to the
man upstairs for making this event the
best it can be
and last but not least thank you to you
guys who have tuned in
who have continuously supported nay saga
throughout the last five years
who have shared watched enjoyed and you
know let somebody know about nay saga
and let somebody know about this event
we look forward to doing more over the
years and we will see you next time
you